alors
aujourd'hui nous allons parler des
énergies renouvelables alors comme en
france on aime beaucoup les définitions
et commencer par les concepts c'est
exactement ce qu'on va faire cette fois
ci donc une énergie renouvelable est
tout simplement une énergie dont le
stock se renouvelle au moins aussi vite
que la vitesse à laquelle on tape dedans
c'est ça le la définition d'une énergie
renouvelable
vous remarquerez que c'est une
définition d'entrepôts centre et donc
c'est renouvelable du point de vue des
échelles de temps qui sont pertinents
pour ce qui concerne l'espèce humaine
sinon la formation des étoiles dans
l'univers et renouvelables alors si on
regarde en pratique ce que cela recouvre
cette affaire là ça recouvre tous qui
déride de la photosynthèse donc la
biomasse et ses dérivés alors ce qui en
dérivent en direct évidemment le pétrole
rentre pas dedans et tous ceux qui
dérive on va dire de l'action du soleil
direct ou indirect sur les éléments dont
quand l'action du soleil direct ou
indirect sur les éléments vous avez la
mise en mouvements de l'atmosphère donc
le vent la mise en mouvement de l'eau
par le cycle de l'eau évaporation
condensation l'action directe
enfin le fait que du rayonnement
électromagnétique nous arrive en direct
etc
évidemment vous ne trouvez pas dedans ce
qui ne correspond pas à cette définition
donc les énergies fossiles
puisque le temps caractéristiques de
reconstitution est hors de proportion
avec les échelles de temps qui intéresse
les hommes et vous ne trouvez pas non
plus le nucléaire qui n'est pas une
énergie fossile mais qui est quand même
une énergie qui dépend de l'existence
d'un métal qui ne se renouvelle pas sur
terre il arrive parfois qu'on trouve
dans la presse que le nucléaire est une
énergie fossile non c'est pas une
énergie renouvelable c'est évidemment
pas une énergie fossile ce qu'on va voir
aujourd'hui c'est que les énergies
renouvelables
en fait cet article défini et de trop
parce que les énergies renouvelables ne
sont absolument pas équivalentes les
unes avec les autres ni en termes de
potentiel ni en termes de facilité
d'utilisation
c'est en fait on a affaire à des choses
qui sont extrêmement variés et pas du
tout homogène et par ailleurs on peut
avoir quelque chose sur lequel je
reviendrai à plusieurs reprises qui est
que l'énergie peut très bien être
renouvelable et son dispositif de
capture non et donc quand vous avez une
énergie renouvelable avec un dispositif
de capture qui est férocement non
renouvelable on va voir que l'on s'en
rapproche pour certaines d'entre elles à
ce moment ça se discute de savoir quel
est le terme dominant dans ce cas les
gènes dominants dans cette histoire 1
est ce que le gène dominant c'est que
c'est renouvelable ou est-ce que le gène
dominant c'est que c'est pas
renouvelables parce qu'on utilise un
dispositif de capture qui ne l'est pas
alors il arrive aussi qu'on met dans les
renouvelables des choses qui sont non
nécessairement totalement renouvelable
voilà il faut juste peut promettre qu'en
cette fin juin vous vous endormirez pas
tout de suite donc le donc il arrive
qu'on met dedans
l'exploitation thermique des déchets est
en fait la fraction des déchets qui est
issu de la biomasse donc à la fois les
déchets organiques divers et le papier
sont considérés comme renouvelables
quand on les brûle en france dans un
incinérateur et que l'on comptabilise
cette partie à la contribution de la
chaleur de l'incinérateur qui est
valorisé ensuite ça ça rentre parfois
dans l'énergie normalement la chaleur de
combustion des plastiques non et enfin
il ya une deuxième énergie qu'on met
parfois dedans a tort qui est l'énergie
géothermique delà de profondes
on verra qu'il ya deux types d'énergie
géothermique en fait quand on quand on
abordera ce sujet une de surface et une
profonde la géothermie profonde consiste
quand même essentiellement à refroidir
la terre mais enfin les ordres de
grandeur sont telles que vous serez tous
morts et moi aussi
avant même si on avait la géothermie
profonde partout avant qu'on est
significativement refroidi la terre en
utilisant la géothermie profonde pour
nos besoins
donc le stock initial est extrêmement
important il n'empêche que c'est pas
tout à fait une énergie renouvelable
la fraction qui est purement
renouvelables dans la géothermie celle
incréments de chaleur qui arrive tous
les ans par la désintégration
radioactive des quelques éléments
radioactifs que vous trouvez à
l'intérieur de la terre ça c'est
renouvelable
pas sûr lula tant qu'il ya de la
décroissance radioactive dans les
énergies renouvelables depuis qu'on sait
qu'on a un problème avec les énergies
fossiles sont des énergies qui font
beaucoup rêver et elles font beaucoup
rêvé pour une raison assez simple c'est
que quand on regarde le potentiel
d'énergies renouvelables 10 pas la
quantité d'énergie renouvelable
disponible sur terre on a affaire à des
ordres de grandeur qui sont extrêmement
importants est considérablement
supérieure à la quantité d'énergie
utilisée par les hommes en particulier
une d1 des ordres de grandeur qu'il est
assez facile de calculer c'est que
l'énergie solaire qui arrive au sommet
de l'atmosphère tous les ans donc avant
réflexion par les nuages les déserts etc
ces dix mille fois la quantité d'énergie
consommée par les hommes au titre avec
le gaz pétrole charbon et c'est donc ce
facteur dix mille fait rêver énormément
de gens dix mille fois rendez vous
compte donc du coup ça va être très
facile de remplacer les énergies
fossiles par des énergies renouvelables
et en particulier par du soleil alors ce
qu'on va voir c'est que en fait c'est
pas si simple que ça parce que les
énergies renouvelables abondantes sont
aussi souvent des énergies renouvelables
diffuse et rappelez-vous ce que je vous
ai dit au cours du premier cours
exploiter de l'énergie pour les hommes
c'est l'extraire de l'environnement là
où elles se trouvent déjà et la mettre
dans un convertisseur
or pour extraire de l'environnement une
énergie qui est très diffuses et de
basse qualité entre guillemets c'est
extrêmement difficile
il ya une énergie qui est pas
renouvelable mais qui est également
disponible en quantité quasi illimité
c'est le rayonnement à 3 quai devigne de
l'univers c'est la source d'énergie la
plus considérable que vous puissiez
regarder et c'est celle dont on ne fera
jamais rien donc le fait que vous ayez
une très grande quantité d'énergie
disponible en théorie est quelque chose
qui ne vous donne pas nécessairement la
facilité qu'il va y avoir à s'en servir
en grande quantité pour remplacer les
énergies fossiles qui sont elles
particulièrement dense et comme mode
d'emploi vous vous rappelez de ce
graphique que je vous avais montré sur
la quantité d'énergie utilisée par les
hommes depuis un siècle et demi alors
cette fois ci j'en ai extrait juste la
partie renouvelables donc ça c'est la
partie énergie renouvelable dans le
graphique que je vous ai montré au
premier cours avec la quantité totale
d'énergie utilisée par les
ce que vous voyez c'est que en quantité
totale les hommes utilisent depuis
longtemps de la biomasse qui reste
aujourd'hui encore la première énergie
entre guillemets renouvelables parce
qu'on va voir que c'est une appellation
qui se discute pour la biomasse et puis
se sont rajoutés quatre types d'énergies
renouvelables qui sont essentiellement
qui sont purement électrique
l'hydroélectricité qui constitue
aujourd'hui le gros de l'énergie
d'origine renouvelable non biomasse et
puis plus récemment comme vous pouvez le
constater ici l'éolien le solaire et le
biogaz et géothermique alors biogaz
géothermie sont dans une même catégorie
dans les statistiques
tout à l'heure je vous montrerai une
tentative de discrimination des oeufs en
ordre de grandeur
ce que vous voyez c'est que ça c'est
très récent et même à l'échelle des
énergies renouvelables s'est pas encore
très important donc quand vous voyez les
énergies renouvelables l'image d'épinal
qu'on devrait vous coller au dessus
c'est pas du tout une éolienne on a pas
d'eau solaire ça serait normalement une
forêt où un barrage
si on était cohérent entre le la réalité
d'aujourd'hui et le qu'est ce que j'ai à
dire et les illustrations qu'on en fait
alors ça c'est à l'échelle des hommes
dans leur ensemble
si je regarde à l'échelle d'un individu
donc pas de l'humanité
ce que vous voyez c'est que la quantité
d'énergie renouvelable utilisée par
personne sur terre elle a plutôt eu
tendance à baisser un peu depuis un
siècle et demi alors la biomasse a
beaucoup baissé
par contre les deux autres évidemment
ont augmenté l'âge et pas discriminer
les nouvelles énergies renouvelables que
vous que vous voyez ici alors la
biomasse dans cette histoire je vous
disais elle est compté comme énergie
renouvelable
alors que ça se discute ça se discute
pas ce qu'une partie de la biomasse
correspond à ce type de processus
vous avez ici alors même si c'est un peu
difficile à distinguer une le nord de
l'europe
vous avez la péninsule danoise la la
baltique
donc là le nord de l'allemagne les pays
bas etc et vous voyez dans cette partie
nord de l'europe
à quoi ressemblait la couverture
forestière en gros il ya un an à milan
et à quoi il ressemble aujourd'hui vous
constatez que il ya eu une déforestation
extrêmement importante
en fait il ya mille ans 80% de l'ordre
du nord était recouverte de forêts à
l'époque d'astérix vous savez très bien
que le petit village était entourée de
forêts que ça et avec la croissance de
la population
les hommes ont défriché une quantité
croissante de forêt et le bois en
général quand il est coupée il est brûlé
alors il peut être soit brûlé et laissé
sur place ses les fameux brûlis soit il
est emporté ailleurs pour servir de bois
de feu au moment où il est coupé et s'il
est emportée ailleurs pour servir de
bois de feu un certain nombre de gens
ont envie de mettre ça dans la catégorie
énergie renouvelable sauf que si c'est
de l'énergie renouvelable qui correspond
aux fassis et du bois qui correspond à
de la déforestation
normalement ça doit pas rentrer dans la
catégorie énergie renouvelable ça doit
rentrer dans la catégorie déforestation
sur la déforestation n'est pas tellement
renouvelables et dans les courbes que je
vous ai montré juste avant donc celle là
est celle là en fait il n'est pas fait
de distinction entre la biomasse
renouvelable et la biomasse pas
renouvelable alors vous verrez un peu
plus tard les statistiques pour la
france aujourd'hui la superficie
forestière française est plutôt stable
ou en légère croissance
donc en france de bois qu'on utilise
peut être considérée comme renouvelables
mais même là vous verrez que c'est pas
simple d'avoir des chiffres
enfin vous verrez pas je vous le dire
tout de suite c'est pas simple d'avoir
des chiffres parce que le bois dans
toutes les énergies que nous utilisons
est la seule qui soit massivement non
commercial le pétrole est massivement
une énergie commercial c'est à dire que
des gens qui ont dans le fond de leur
jardin puits de pétrole où ils vont
chercher leur pétrole comme on va
chercher de l'eau qu'ensuite il distille
dans leur propre alambic dans leur cave
pour alimenter leur voiture il y en a
quand même pas beaucoup des gens qui ont
leurs propres mines de charbon dans le
fond de leur jardin pour alimenter
ensuite leurs poils il y en a pas
beaucoup non plus il y en a déjà un peu
plus une bonne partie des mines de
charbon par exemple en chine sur les
mines artisanales et une en chine
vous avez une partie significative du
chauffage qui est fait dans des poêles à
charbon
mais globalement les énergies fossiles
et le nucléaire et l'électricité d'une
façon générale sont des énergies
commercial et si ce sont des énergies
commercial ça veut dire qu'il ya un
vendeur donc un sales capitalistes
parfois un seul communiste qui a
aucunement l'intention de vous servir
gratuitement et donc qui met des
compteurs partout pour vérifier que vous
n'allez pas consommer plus que ce qui
vous vend du reste il a très envie de
savoir combien il vous vend donc vous
avez des statistiques qui sont à peu
près fiable donc dans toutes les
énergies commercial on arrive à suivre
les quantités utilisées parce que il ya
quelqu'un à qui profite le crime qui
sont d'une part le vendeur et d'autre
part l'état parce que toutes les
énergies commerciales font l'objet d'une
fiscalité et à partir du moment où vous
avez une fiscalité vous regarder
l'assiette de très près par exemple en
france on sait très bien combien
consomme de carburant vous avez une taxe
sur les carburants et donc vous avez des
corps des instruments de mesure qu'ils
vérifient toutes les pompes à essence
sont exactes le bois est essentiellement
une énergie d'autoconsommation alors à
part quelques urbain qui installent des
poêles à bois et qui achètent du bois
d'autres qu'il déclare pas toujours se
dit en passant le bois est globalement
une énergie d'autoconsommation donc là
pour le coup vous allez vraiment dans le
fond de votre parcelle de bois ramassé
quelques stères que vous allez utiliser
ensuite pour vous chauffer c'est une
énergie de circuits courts par
excellence et autres piques
c'est également une énergie qui est très
importante pour le bois de feu donc pour
faire la cuisine avec une efficacité
déplorable c'est un des problèmes du
reste et là c'est pareil vous avez ou
bien de l'économie informelle ou bien de
l'autoconsommation et dans les deux cas
de figure beaucoup de difficultés à
avoir des statistiques fiables
alors vous pourriez me dire oui mais on
peut éventuellement mesurer la quantité
de bois qu'on utilise d'une autre façon
par exemple avec des photos satellites
on regarde qui avait la surface couverte
par les forêts alors même ça c'est pas
simple parce que quand vous avez des
arbres qui sont coupés sur une photo
dans la forêt et que ça se passe sur une
échelle qui est sous la résolution du
pixel vous voyez pas donc si vous couper
un arbre sur 100 dans une forêt où un
arbre sur 50
vous voyez pas ça sur les images
satellites donc vous pouvez très bien
avoir donc la consommation de bois
j'insiste est quelque chose qui est
estimé donc ce que je vous montre là à
la fois sur cette courbe et sur celle là
parce que c'est les mêmes avec la
population qui intervient ce sont des
estimations
c'est beaucoup moins fiable on à l'ordre
de grandeur mais c'est beaucoup moins
fiable c'est à quelques dizaines de
pourcent près selon donc une partie du
bois qu'on utilise
j'insiste là dessus c'est de la
déforestation et la limite à
l'utilisation du bois j'y reviendrai
plus tard c'est tout simplement la
photosynthèse
c'est à dire que vous ne pouvez pas en
mode renouvelable utilisée chaque année
plus de bois que ce que la photosynthèse
vous a fourni donc le seuil de
renouvellement d'une forêt c'est
l'accroissement annuel
c'est ça qu'on appelle dans le jargon
forestier la crue annuel c'est
l'accroissement annuel de la biomasse
résultant de la photosynthèse donc temps
que vous utilisez ça au moins vous êtes
en mode renouvelable
si vous utilisez plus que ça vous êtes
en mode pas renouvelable et j'insiste
comme il ya beaucoup de circuits ils
sont les circuits non commerciaux ou
informel c'est difficile de savoir
exactement combien ce que les gens vont
piocher dans une forêt dans laquelle ils
vont piocher
alors je rappelle également une autre
chose avec une courbe que je vous avait
déjà montré celle là
il ressemble vous avez ici les trois
familles d'énergie que nous utilisons
sur terre aujourd'hui donc les énergies
renouvelables les énergies fossiles et
l'énergie nucléaire ou les énergies
nucléaires plus exactement
est ce que vous voyez c'est que
l'énergie renouvelable qui représentait
la quasi-totalité du fonctionnement de
l'humanité il ya deux siècles et même la
totalité il ya trois siècles et bien sa
part n'a pas cessé de diminuer au cours
de l'essor industriel pour tomber à des
valeurs très basses qui sont
raisonnablement stable depuis donc une
blague qui m'arrive souvent de faire et
de dire un monde 100 % renouvelable je
sais très bien à quoi ça correspond j'ai
au moins un point d enfin project à
manger au moins un point
d'échantillonnage où je vois très bien à
quoi ça correspond c'est le monde ya
trois siècles et le monde ya trois
siècles
c'est 700 millions sept cent millions
d'habitants sur terre avec une espérance
de vie à la naissance légèrement
inférieure à 30 ans et l'essentiel des
gens agriculteurs dont 100% renouvelable
il ya au moins une situation dans
laquelle je sais que ça marche
maintenant la question évidemment c'est
est ce qu'on a le moindre espoir que ça
marche aussi dans avec une humanité de 8
milliards d'individus qui ont envie
d'avoir des baskets pour pas cher livrée
par amazon et de pouvoir aller au cinéma
quand ça leur chante et deux passes
casser le dos toute la journée et ça
vous allez voir que la réponse c'est une
réponse de normand peut-être ben qu'oui
ptêt ben qu'non avec probablement à
peut-être maintenant j est un peu plus
fort que l'autre y avait une question
oui c'est quelqu'un qui avait non oui ça
vaut c'est pas parce que ça vous grattez
souvent non ça c'est parce que j'ai fait
ce matin une copie d'écran et c'est une
7 la souris je crois
[Rires]
voyez je crois à non non non non pardon
je vous dis non non je vous dis une
connerie je sais pas ce que c'est c'est
un c'est un artefact de temps en temps
il ya des oscillations de la courbe
[Musique]
s'est pas significatif alors aujourd'hui
les énergies renouvelables ça représente
donc 16 % de la quantité d'énergie
primaire que nous utilisons donc ça
qu'on extrait de l'environnement les
chiffres que vous avez là dessous je
vous rappelle encore une fois que la
primaire est finale pour l'énergie et
que pour l'électricité qui est fait avec
de la chaleur il ya une énorme
différence entre les deux alors pour
l'électricité qui est pas faite avec de
la chaleur
typiquement le vent ou
l'hydroélectricité il ya toujours une
épée en éternel débat de savoir si ça
doit être compté en équivalent en finale
ou un équivalent primaires là c'est
compté en équivalent primaires c'est
donc la version la plus favorable
possible aux énergies renouvelables
purement électrique lorsque vous voyez
aujourd'hui c'est que le bois
aux dernières nouvelles parce que
l'année dernière je pensais que c'était
disent maintenant cette année j'ai
d'autres chiffres qui me disent que
c'est cette bon c'est ce que je vous
disais à 30% preuve mettez en ordre de
grandeur que c'est un petit 10 % de la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise dans le
monde mais la fraction renouvelables et
sûrement pas de 10%
elle est plus bas l'hydroélectricité est
donc la première des énergies
renouvelables hors biomasse que nous
consommons et vous voyez que en
équivalent en primaire ça fait à peu
près pareil que le bois en équivalent
finale évidemment ce serait trois fois
moins devient le 58 faut au moins
ensuite arrive le vent alors le vent a
significativement augmenté ces dernières
années
mais vous voyez que ça ne représente
encore avec la convention la plus
favorable que un gros 1 % de l'énergie
primaire et par ailleurs si vous vous
rappelez bien de ce que je vous avais
montré au premier cours ça pendant que
le vent augmentait le charbon a augmenté
cinq fois plus vite donc c'est là je
reste dans les énergies renouvelables
évidemment après vous avez les
agrocarburants ici qui vous représente
une fraction 2%
et pourtant et pourtant les
agrocarburants en consomment déjà 40 %
du maïs cultivés aux etats-unis 40% pour
faire de l'éthanol
sachant que les états unis sont le
premier producteur de maïs au monde avec
à peu près un tiers de la production
mondiale
donc si vous faites un tiers de 40% ça
vous fait à peu près ça vous fait 13
morts et quelque chose et je vous ai mis
14 parce qu'il ya un peu de maïs qui est
utilisé pour faire des agrocarburants
ailleurs y compris en france
en france vous avez également dû des
agrocarburants qui sont faits avec du
maïs du blé et des betteraves
c'est ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler j'y
reviendrai après les agrocarburants de
première génération et enfin ici vous
avez le solaire photovoltaïque qui
représente aussi une fraction 2% alors
même si ça augmente rapidement sa part
de très très bas et c'est une fraction 2
% de l'énergie mondiale aujourd'hui et
la question qu'on peut se poser
évidemment c'est est-ce que ça va
continuer à augmenter aussi vite
qu'aujourd'hui ou pas ou est-ce qu'à des
facteurs limitants qui font que c'est
pas sûr que ça continue d'augmenter à
cette vitesse oui les biocarburants ils
sont aujourd'hui j'ai réagi à une partie
qu'ils en parlent plus tard vous verrez
ça alimente des engins de transport
essentiellement donc en fait c'est
mélangé à l'essence ou au diesel s'est
incorporé à l'essence et au diesel est
servi avec l' essence et diesel par
exemple en france vous avez une
obligation d'incorporation de
biocarburants à hauteur de quelques
pourcents je me rappelle plus du chiffre
exact 6,7 dans l'est dans les carburants
pétroliers
aujourd'hui quand vous achetez un
carburant pétrolier en fait il ya
quelques pourcents biocarburants il y
avait une autre de nos questions ça
c'est vraiment tête c'est pas marqué
hachez désolé c'est des millions de
tonnes équivalent pétrole
oui le biogaz c1 c'est un gaz qui est
fait avec de la fermentation de matière
végétale ou de résidus animaux
typiquement des déjections la grèce dont
on veut pas après abattage des animaux
en fait comme ça voilà et après contre
est ce à plusieurs utilisations
la principale d'entre elles aujourd'hui
en france et encore plus en allemagne
c'est de faire de l'électricité
donc en fait c'est une petite centrale à
gaz sauf que le gaz est d'origine
végétale
vous pouvez également vous en servir
pour le liquéfier et faire avancer des
engins de transport qui roulent au gaz
naturel liquéfié gnl et ce gaz naturel
vous pouvez remplacer par du biogaz vous
pouvez également l'injecter dans le
réseau gaz et à ce moment c'est vous
l'utiliser comme du gaz pour du
chauffage ou wee aa
bonne question on verra ça dans le bilan
carbone des biocarburants tout à l'heure
bien sûr ça compte si vous avez un
biocarburant qui est issu de surface qui
ont été soit déforester pour l'occasion
soit qui était anciennement consacrée à
des cultures alimentaires mais du coup
avec une pression qui se reportent sur
la déforestation
c'est pire que si vous utilisez du
pétrole
oui non pardon idol c'est l'énergie des
vagues
c'est wade idol c'est le non non c'est
c'est pas assez
non non non non je pense que c'est
maintenant je pense que c'est l'énergie
des vagues de l'énergie des marées je
crois vous avez trois centrales
marémotrices au monde on en a une dans
la rance il y en a une au canada dans la
baie d'hudson silva est moribonde et
puis je me demande si on n'a pas une
troisième qui compara et ça doit
s'arrêter là non c'est vraiment marie
les vagues c'est ça n'existe même pas
dans ce tableau faisait des bêtises
c'est bon alors si on regarde maintenant
la france on constate qu'en france la
hiérarchie de l'utilisation des énergies
renouvelables est exactement la même que
celle que nous avons dans le monde
en gros c'est à dire que ce qui arrive
en premier c'est le bois essentiellement
pour le chauffage ce qui arrive en
second c'est l'hydroélectricité si vous
regardez attentivement vous verrez qu'il
y en a un peu moins aujourd'hui qu'il ya
quelques décennies la raison étant que
le régime pluviométrique a tendance à
diminuer légèrement et enfin vous avez
ici éoliens et photovoltaïques qui sont
secondaires au sein des énergies
renouvelables on a une grosse exception
en europe qui est l'allemagne j'y
reviendrai plus tard parce que je
traiterai son cas un peu plus en détail
ce que vous voyez c'est que le le
vous avez des termes là qui sont pas
complètement qui sont pas complètement
négligeable qui sont ici les agro
carburants bio essence diesel
et puis ici les pompes à chaleur les
pompes à chaleur je reviendrai après
aussi alors maintenant on va rentrer
dans l'inventeur l'énumération on va
dire de toutes ces énergies
renouvelables le la première dont on va
parler c'est l'exploitation solaire oui
j'y viens après la réponse est qu'il est
à peu près totalement exploité mais
viendrait après la première la première
énergie qu'on va regarder oui c'est
l'exploitation directe du flux solaire
alors l'exploitation directe du fus
solaire c'est l'exploitation de la
partie qui arrive à terre évidemment ce
n'est pas la partie qui arrive au sommet
de l'atmosphère parce que celle là elle
est réfléchie par les nuages et donc
elle est un peu loin en ce qui nous
concerne est ce que vous voyez c'est que
la partie qui arrivent là représentent
un peu plus de 200 watts par mètre carré
en moyenne annuelle
alors c'est une moyenne géographique et
temporelle géographique et temporelle si
vous allez donc ça inclut à la fois ce
qui arrive près des pôles où ils
arrivent pas beaucoup et ce qui arrive
aux tropiques et ce qui arrive en été et
ce qui arrive en hiver quand vous êtes
envoyé de l'attitude sachant que bien
évidemment il n'arrête pas la même chose
et ce qui arrive le jour et ce qui règle
la nuit sachant que la nuit par
définition il arrive rien donc c'est une
moyenne
encore une fois géographique et
temporelle si on regarde le cas de la
france
on voit que cette installation au sol
elle sans grande surprise augmente quand
on va de chez les ch'tis vers chez les
marseillais et que par ailleurs même à
l'attitude données elle n'est pas
homogène
alors est ce que vous savez pourquoi
elle est plus faible ici
que la à la même latitude exactement à
cause des nuages
d'où viennent les dépressions en france
de l'ouest qui amène les dépressions des
nuages et donc la nébulosité et plus
important de près de l'atlantique que
près de la méditerranée et donc
l'insolation annuelle est plus
importante près de la méditerranée que
près de l'atlantique et vous voyez que
le gradient est pas complètement
ridicule c'est pas c'est pas une
variation de 3% donc si vous voulez du
soleil c'est mieux d'aller au sud
et c'est mieux d'aller près de la
méditerranée il se trouve que le plus
grand parc installé en europe et au nord
parce que c'est au bord du rhin c'est
comme ça alors la première manière
d'exploiter cette énergie c'est tout
simplement de chauffer de l'air ou de
l'eau
alors il ya une première planche que
j'aurais pu vous montrer et que je ne
vous montre pas mais vous allez trouver
tout seul de quoi il s'agit la première
exploitation en fait en ordre de
grandeur et de très loin de l'énergie
solaire c'est ça non non j'ai entendu le
chauffage
c'est le chauffage des bâtiments tous
maintenant vous avez pas besoin
d'allumer le chauffage de l'été dieu
c'est le c2 très loin le premier rapport
dans l'utilisation de l'énergie par les
hommes et du reste vous pouvez accroître
ce terme en mettant des fenêtres au
dessus des vérandas et c'est dans la
réhabilitation thermique des bâtiments
par exemple si vous n'avez pas de
problème d'espacé au sol et que vous
avez une façade côté sud une des
opérations classiques consiste à
rajouter une véranda encore rajouter une
surface vitrée et l'hiver ça vous sert
de radiateur ça vous fait une serre quoi
l'air chaud rentrer dans la maison
ça marche très très bien la deuxième
manière qu'on peut avoir d'exploiter
cette énergie thermique
c'est de faire de l'eau pour se laver ou
de l'eau pour se chauffer alors l'eau
pour se laver c'est assez simple parce
que vous avez vous mettez une surface de
capteurs sur le toit alors là c'est la
douche solaire pour ceux d'entre vous
qui en est déjà utilisé une autre en
ping donc c'est une surface noire
devant laquelle vous faites passer de
l'eau ça chauffe l'eau et sauf que c'est
plus gros qu'une douche solaire quand
vous êtes chez vous parce que vous
prenez en général des douches qui sont
un peu plus copieuse et à ce moment
l'eau chaude va chauffer un cumulus
comme qui est la com com un cumulus
normale dont vous vous servez ensuite
pour prendre des douches
l'autre option ça peut être d'utiliser
la chaleur fournie par cette eau pour
chauffer l'intérieur d'un logement
alors là vous ne chauffez pas avec l'air
avec l'air avec le soleil qui rentre par
les fenêtres ou l'air chaud qui rentrent
par la véranda
vous allez faire rentrer la chaleur par
un circuit d'eau également et ensuite ce
circuit d'eau va relarguer les calories
à l'intérieur de la maison
cela étant comme un circuit d'eau qui
vous capte la chaleur c'est pas à très
haute température c'est quand même moins
chaud globalement ce circuit d'eau que
ce que vous avez en sortie de chaudières
ont un chauffage central
vous avez besoin de surfaces radiante
qui sont plus importantes que ce que
vous avez avec un chauffage central
classique donc malheureusement on ne
peut pas faire un rétro fit sur les
maisons existantes qui ont des
radiateurs qui ont été dimensionnés pour
de l'eau à 60 degrés pour y faire passer
du chauffage solaire avec de l'eau qui a
été chauffée dehors en plein hiver à 40
ou 45 degrés d'accord vous pouvez pas
donc ça ne marche que si vous cassez
tous les radiateurs pour les remplacer
par des radiateurs quatre fois plus gros
ou bien si vous avez un plancher
chauffant
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
maisons qui sont chauffés au soleil avec
des capteurs solaires sur le toit
en général elles sont équipées quand
elles sont construites comme ça elles
sont équipées d'un plancher chauffant et
vous avez donc un chauffage par le sol
pour avoir une très très grande surface
radiante à une température pas très
élevé
alors cette énergie solaire là est assez
en vogue sous les tropiques sous les
tropiques vous avez dans l'est dans les
territoires de trauner en france vous
avez pas mal de logement qui sont
équipés avec du chauffage avec des
chauffe eau solaires de cette nature
notamment parce que les tropiques ne
sont pas équipés de réseaux de gaz donc
c'est soit de l'électricité soit du
fioul et les énergies concurrentes et en
plus cher que le gaz en france l'énergie
la moins chère pour chauffer de l'eau
ces deux gars mais sous les tropiques
vous n'avez pas de réseau de gaz en
général donc à ce moment les énergies
concurrentes c'est le fioul et
l'électricité et les deux énergies
concurrentes sont significativement plus
cher et donc ça peut valoir le coup
comme il ya beaucoup plus de soleil de
mettre ce genre de chauffe-eau la
deuxième exploitation du soleil c'est
l'effet photoélectrique et l'effet
photoélectrique donc comme vous le savez
c'est la création d'un courant dans une
matière qui est du silicium avec des
petits trous et des petits électrons en
trop avec des éléments qu'on a mis
soigneusement là où il fallait
c'est la création d'un courant quand
vous exposer cette matière au soleil
alors des panneaux solaires vous en
avait de toutes les tailles
là par exemple cours d'un colloque on va
faire un petit gadget wilkie ce sac à
dos et ça c'est un panneau solaire
voilà je m'en suis rendu compte parce
que je voulais m'asseoir dessus d'un
jardin du luxembourg et on dit qu'il
fallait que je fasse ça voilà donc vous
en avez toutes les dimensions je vous
montrerai après qu'ils sont un peu plus
gros que ça donc l'idée du panneau
solaire c'est évidemment encore une fois
que ça vous donne du courant quand y'a
du soleil alors c'est très bien parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de soleil partout mais
vous allez voir que par ailleurs il ya
un certain nombre de limitations parce
que du soleil comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il y en a pas toute la journée
alors que l'électricité on aime bien
utiliser toute la journée
et puis vous avez par ailleurs une
densité de puissance avec ce genre
d'installation qui n'est pas extrêmement
élevé la manière dont fonctionne
aujourd'hui en france
l'installation de l'énergie solaire
c'est que très peu de sites font de
l'électricité pour la consommer eux même
en étant autonome à part le refuge du
dôme du goûter et quelques autres
baraques de cette nature
règle générale c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche en fait on a favorisé les
installations connectées au réseau parce
qu'il y avait des objectifs
d'augmentation des honneurs dans tous
les pays européens et que les nerfs qui
ont été favorisées en premier dans tous
les pays européens sont les eaux ar
électriques précisé pourquoi plus tard
enfin en tout cas mon hypothèse sur
pourquoi plus tard et du coup le but du
jeu c'est pas nécessairement que vous
ayez un peu d'électricité pour vous
c'est que vous ayez de l'électricité
pour mettre sur le réseau donc la façon
dont ça fonctionne en france c'est que
vous avez quand vous avez une
installation photo électriques
vous avez deux contrats différents vous
avez un contrat qui concerne
l'installation et qui vous fait injecter
l'électricité sur le réseau avec un
tarif d'achat qui est garanti qui est à
prix fixe est garanti et de l'autre côté
pour votre consommation vous avez un
contrat normal de consommateurs
d'électricité encore et les deux sont
séparés c'est une autre manière de dire
que le développement des deux du
photovoltaïque en france et fait comme
une activité économique et non pas fait
comme un élément de consommation
personnelle c'est essentiellement une
activité économique
en gros vous louez votre façade sud de
toi exactement comme vous l'auriez une
surface pour une boutique vous êtes
propriétaire du commerce mais c'est
exactement ce principe alors l'image
d'épinal jusqu'à récemment c'était le
panneau sur le toit en fait alors ce
graphique il a été arrêté après 2014
mais ça vous donne quand même une
indication en fait l'essentiel des
surfaces photovoltaïques qui sont
développés qui ont été développées en
france aujourd'hui sont des grandes
surfaces photovoltaïques donc l'énergie
solaire photovoltaïque en france comme
dans beaucoup d'autres pays c'est pas
une énergie de particulier c'est une
énergie d'industriels comme les autres
vous avez des développeurs de projets
qui sont des gens qui trouvent des
terrains ou trouve des grands bâtiments
font réaliser l'installation
si le contrat à tarif garanti paye les
charges encaisse les résultats et ont un
résultat net c'est des opérateurs et des
entreprises qui font ça pour l'essentiel
des surfaces qui sont installés en
photovoltaïque en france
voilà par exemple une photo aérienne
de la plus grande centrale solaire au
sol installée en france
alors retenez que le photovoltaïque au
sol est à ses consommateurs des espaces
puisque vous avez besoin d'un hectare
par mégawatt de puissance et c'est un
hectare qui est mobilisé en quasi
totalité alors il ya des gens qui se
disent on peut en faire des ombres et
hier les mettre à trois mètres du sol
faire pousser des fraises en dessous etc
mais globalement c'est quand même un
hectare qui est mobilisé en quasi
totalité
une autre manière de dire ça c'est que
sur un kilomètre carré c'est à dire 10
hectares vous mettez 10 mégawatts de
puissance un kilomètre carré pour faire
tout de suite la comparaison qui vous
intéressent c'est également l'emprise
d'une centrale nucléaire sur laquelle
vous avez 4 gigawatts de puissance donc
10 mégawatts 4 gigawatts 400 fois plus
donc le photovoltaïque au sol est très
consommateur d'espacé un de ses
inconvénients
la deuxième particularité du
photovoltaïque c'est que alors ici vous
avez quelque chose que je vous ai sorti
enfin je les fais ce matin sur le site
de rte
vous avez ici la puissance injectée sur
le réseau
jour après jour sur quasiment deux mois
alors ne demandez pas pourquoi le
brillant polytechnicien qui travaille
chez rte ne permet pas que l'on regarde
ça sur deux mois c'est sur 54 jours
pourquoi 54 son chiffre fétiche quand
ils jouent au loto mais enfin bon c'est
quasiment deux mois et donc ce que vous
voyez c'est que vous avez évidemment un
maximum tous les jours mais que ce
maximum
il peut varier d'un facteur 2 à 3 en
l'espace de quelques jours et ça c'est
l'effet justement de la début lose it
est beaucoup plus de nuages il fait
mauvais il pleut et vous vous retrouvez
avec une puissance qui est fortement
variable donc la partie prévisible de à
long terme j'ai envie de dire de
l'énergie solaire elle est là elle n'est
pas là dans la mesure où trois mois al
avance
vous connaissez l'inclinaison de l'axé
de rotation de la terre sur le plan
d'orbites dont vous savez qu'elle sera
l'insolation par contre vous savez pas
quelle sera la nébulosité donc ce que
vous êtes cap ce sur quoi vous savez que
vous pouvez table et de façon absolument
certaine c'est
la fraction du potentiel que vous avez
avec une forte nébulosité un jour y
flotte en gros c'est là dessus que vous
pouvez table et pas sur quelque chose et
vous voyez qu'il ya encore un facteur
d'incertitude de 2 à 3 par rapport à ce
que vous pouvez avoir au maximum
vous voyez également quelque chose
absolument évident sur ce graphique et
j'y reviendrai plus tard c'est que la
fourniture s'interrompt toutes les nuits
je le répète un la nuit par définition
c'est qu'on n'y a pas de soleil ce qui
veut dire que si on veut avoir un
approvisionnement significatif
significatif pardon en provenance de
l'énergie solaire dans l'est dans les
scénarios dans certains scénarios très
optimiste sur les énergies renouvelables
à 2050
vous avez le solaire et l'éolien qui
peuvent atteindre 30 % chacun de
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
je dis bien énergétique un pas
électrique et à ce moment ce que vous
voyez immédiatement en regardant ce
graphique c'est que ça pose à l'évidence
la question de savoir qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand on est là c'est évidemment
une question qui se pose tout de suite j
aurais je vous ai dit tout à l'heure on
peut très bien avoir une énergie qui
renouvelables et son dispositif de
capture qui ne l'est pas alors en
l'occurrence le solaire photovoltaïque
correspond aussi à cette définition
puisque le soleil est parfaitement
renouvelables enfin en tout cas pour que
le soleil ne se renouvelle plus il va
falloir attendre 4 milliards d'années
donc ça sera plus tellement de problèmes
ni le mien
par contre pour capturer l'énergie
solaire aujourd'hui vous utilisez des
panneaux photovoltaïques qui nécessite
d'utiliser un certain nombre de
matériaux qui sont parfaitement non
renouvelable il faut utiliser de l'acier
il faut utiliser du cuivre il faut
utiliser du silicium
il faut utiliser des dopants il faut
utiliser de l'aluminium
il faut utiliser du verre alors là
dedans il ya des matériaux pour lesquels
le problème de stock
vous serez mort et moi aussi à
l'humanité aussi qu'on n'en a toujours
pas de problème de disponibilité
par contre vous en avez d'autres
typiquement le faire par contre vous en
avez d'autres pour lesquels vous pouvez
avoir un vrai problème de disponibilité
pas au sens où il y en aura plus mais au
sens où on commencera à voir de vrais
problèmes pour avoir des mines avec des
concentrations qui font que on obtient
quelque chose avec un effort raisonnable
et ça se matérialise le fait que les
énergies renouvelables est un dispositif
de capture qui n'est pas renouvelable
par le fait que vous avez du coup
utilisation de matériaux non
renouvelable qu'il a bien fallu
fabriquer dans le dispositif de capture
et dont vous avez des émissions de co2
liées à la fabrication du dispositif de
capture alors là vous avez des ordres de
grandeur pour comparaison
ici vous avez les émissions liées à la
production d'un kilowattheure au charbon
est donc ce que vous avez là c'est que
vous retrouvez le kilo par kilowattheure
dont je vous avais parlé au moment où on
avait parlé des énergies fossiles alors
ça se baladent selon la technologie que
vous faites de l'ultra supercritique
machin chouette où vous êtes dans une
vieille centrale pourri c'est cela c'est
ça la marge ici vous avez les émissions
sur une centrale à gaz à cycle combiné
c'est une technologie raisonnablement
récente ya pas trop de sens rac pourris
dont je posais pas mieux en rire bas et
après vous passez dans d'autres d'autres
types de productions qui sont dites non
fossile donc ici vous avez le nucléaire
ici vous avez l'éolien sans stockage
ici vous avez le photovoltaïque sans
stockage c'est-à-dire brut brut de
fonderie
en sortie de en sortie de panneaux est
ici si vous stockez sur batterie alors
là en sortie de panneaux vous voyez que
vous avez ça peut varier et la raison
pour laquelle ça peut varier c'est que
ça dépend de la manière dont vous allez
fabriquer le panneau exactement du pays
dans lequel vous avez fabriqué le
panneau comme fabriquer un panneau
solaire s'effondre du silicium et que ça
de et que c'est que la métallurgie qui
se fait avec de l'électricité
si vous êtes en chine vous allez avoir
un contenu carbone de votre silicium
fondue qui sera très supérieur au
contenu carbone si vous faites ça en
france par ailleurs derrière la quantité
de kilowattheures que vous allez avoir
par en dépend comme je voulais montrer
tout à l'heure de la latitude et de la
début lose it est donc là les valeurs
que vous avez c'est pour la france
selon vous êtes au nord ou au sud et que
vous avez fait fabriquer le panneau ici
plutôt que là vous voyez que vous vous
baladez entre 30 et 80 grammes de co2
par kilowattheure mais si comme je le
disais tout à l'heure vous vous posez
également la question de savoir ce que
vous faites quand ya pas de soleil et
donc que vous stockez à ce moment là
j'ai pris l'hypothèse du stockage sur
batterie / barrage réversible ce serait
évidemment beaucoup moins que ça sur
batterie vous avez besoin de fabriquer
la patrie c'est de la métallurgie aussi
et un kilowattheure stocker restituer
sur une batterie c'est n'importe quoi
entre 50 et 200 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure électrique 1 qui j'ai pris
une valeur médiane est par ailleurs
quand vous stockez et que vous déstocker
vous allez perdre une partie de
l'électricité que vous avez stocker vous
avez une perte qui est de l'ordre de 20%
donc si vous donc ça veut dire que vous
devez surdimensionné votre production
pour la partie il sera stocké de 1 sur
0,8 d'accord donc un peu plus de 20%
si vous mettez boutabout les émissions
supplémentaires liés au fait que vous
avez produit de l'électricité qui ne
sert qu'à compenser les pertes de
stockage et les émissions de fabrication
de la batterie voilà vous arrivé à la
conclusion que un kilowattheure
photovoltaïque stockées sur batterie ça
se baladent quelque part entre 100 et
250 grammes de co2 oui
alors j'ai pas regardé la durée dit
qu'ils étaient prises dans la cvs de
mémoire ses 25 ans ou 30 ans après en
fait vous avez des panneaux qui peuvent
continuer à fonctionner mais avec des
rendements dégradé en fait c'est ça le
sessad sujet la question de la durée de
vie est toujours un truc qui est très
comment dire piégeux dans les analyses
de cycle de vie
parce que par exemple pour les bâtiments
les durée conventionnelle ses 50 ans et
bien évidemment on construit pas des
bâtiments pour qu'il s'écrase au bout de
cinquante ans sauf les espèces de
commerce de boîtes métalliques
dégueulasse pour faire les commerces de
banlieue là où effectivement ça on
compte pas trop dessus mais sinon des
vous faites un logement c'est évident
qu'il n'est pas il construit pas pour
qu'il s'effondre tout seul dans 50 ans
voilà donc vous avez des durée
conventionnelle sur le photovoltaïque
c'est entre 25 c 25 ou 30 ans alors
après il ya un autre sujet c'est que le
quand on regarde le rendement
énergétique du photovoltaïque l'anc là
je vous ai parlé de l'empreinte carbone
mais on peut également s'intéresser à
son rendement énergétique
il ya une question intéressante alors je
vais pas vous tous vous énumérez là
dedans mais il ya une question
intéressante de savoir où est ce que
j'arrête le périmètre de ce que je
prends en compte parce que voyez là il
ya un ingénieur espagnol qui en
l'occurrence est un ancien du
photovoltaïque
il a il a passé son temps à installer et
à gérer des parcs photovoltaïques en
espagne qui un jour s'est amusé à faire
le calcul de que donne le retour sur
investissement énergétique du
photovoltaïque c'est à dire combien
d'années de fonctionnement du panneau il
faut pour rembourser l'énergie de
fabrication du panneau c'est ça le
calcul qu'il a fait et il a dit je vais
pas prendre que le panneau je vais
prendre le panneau je vais prendre son
installation parce qu'il faut des
camionnettes au pétrole pour venir
installer le panneau il faut du ciment
pour les fondations il faut de l'acier
il faut venir laver le panneau à
intervalles réguliers
du reste le qatar je crois à des
problèmes avec son photovoltaïque parce
que quand il dépend en fait de sable ça
colle plein de sable sur le panneau
après vous pouvez pas le nettoyer comme
ça parce que le sable gris le vert vous
pouvez pas le nettoyer à l'eau parce
qu'il ya pas d'eau pouvait pas de
nettoyer à l'eau de mer parce que ça
laisse du sel partout enfin bref ils ont
ils sont alors qu'ils dînaient avec
cette opération d'après ce que j'ai
compris
mais le met donc il faut il faut laver
il faut mettre une clôture auto il faut
passer à intervalles réguliers vérifier
que tout va bien il faut mettre des
onduleurs et forme et il faut également
cet ingénieur est allé jusqu'au bout des
gens dans des bureaux qui font des
études pour savoir où est ce qu'on va
installer le parc photovoltaïque des
autorisations administratives etc
donc il a fait la contrepartie de tout
ça et alors ça va il ya quelques années
donc évidemment ça s'est amélioré depuis
mais il ya quelques années il disait ben
voila en gros pour un investi dans la
fabrication du panneau photovoltaïque et
de tous qui l'entourent
je vais ressortir trois sur sa durée dit
dit autrement si on considère que la
durée de vie de l'installation ses 25
ans et bien la fabrication de
l'installation et l'énergie qu'il faut
utiliser pour faire fonctionner les
ingénieurs qui dit mentionne le machin
etc etc
en fait ça représente l'équivalent de 80
fonctionnement alors encore une fois
c'est à dire quelques années c'est
quelque chose qui évidemment s'est
améliorée depuis
mais voilà c'est un exercice intéressant
parce que alors je ne rentrerai pas dans
des tailles aujourd'hui mais il ya des
gens qui ont théorisé que le retour sûr
que le rendement du système énergétique
pour qu'on ait une société élaboré il
faut qu'il soit supérieur à 12 ou 13
c'est à dire qu' il faut que vous ayez
un retour sur investissement énergétique
qui soit supérieur à 12 ou 13 pour qu'on
ait une société élaboré dans laquelle
les gens ont le temps d'aller faire des
études à l'école des mines et non pas
soient tous occupés à faire pousser
leurs seins nourriture alors j'ai pas
été vérifiée le multiple en tout cas ça
me paraît à peu près évident qu'à 3 ça
marche pas et même à 5 à mon avis ça
marche pas bien
vous avez une dernière manière
d'exploiter le rayonnement solaire à des
fins énergétiques
alors c'est toujours dans le domaine
électrique mais cette fois ci c'est avec
de la concentration oui
alors sur le pétrole à ses débuts si
vous excluez le raffinage vous êtes à un
sur cent donc en gros il fallait
investir 1 pour faire sortir sans d'un
puits de pétrole le pétrole aujourd'hui
on est plutôt à 1 sur 1 sur 10 en
moyenne
le pétrole de schiste ou les sables
bitumineux on est à 1 sur 3 ou un sur
quatre donc là ça commence à être
vraiment pas terrible le nucléaire si
vous demandez aux gens qui travaillent
de dents ils vous disent 1 sur 60 si
vous demandez aux antinucléaires et vous
dise un sur cinq
mais en l'occurrence pour avoir fait les
calculs je pense qu'on est beaucoup plus
proche du 1 sur 60 normes et les anti
nucléaires il vous sort toutes les
hypothèses tout le corps sauf le truc le
plus favorable possible il vous
enrichisse l'uranium avec des centrales
à charbon match si vous si vous regardez
l'hydroélectricité c'est pas mal
l'hydroélectricité c1 sur quelques
dizaines
voilà le c'est clair que les
biocarburants on le verra plus tard ça
peut être un pour 1 1 pour 1,2 en
dédiant donc vous avez voilà donc dans
les énergies fossiles historique
j'ai envie de le gazon était importante
enfin donc dans les énergies fossiles
historique vous êtes un pur plusieurs
dizaines et c'est ça qui a permis de
faire la société très sophistiqué dans
laquelle on vit les énergies
renouvelables diffuse typiquement le
soleil ont en général des ratios
beaucoup plus bas et c'est ça qui fait
dire un certain nombre de gens que ça
sera compliqué d'avoir une société
élaboré sur la base simplement de ces
énergies donc pour ça qu'il faut pas
s'en servir mais veut dire ça fait
partie des contreparties oui dernier
point a donc vous avez le solaire à
concentration alors le solaire à
concentration on prête à archimède de
l'avoir utilisée il ya longtemps pour
mettre en déroute les bateaux ennemis à
idées grands miroirs paraboliques et
plus récemment on s'en sert pour faire
des centrales qui sont aussi des
centrales électriques et qu'on appelle
des centrales thermodynamiques alors là
le principe c'est de retrouver une
machine de carnot dit autrement vous
utilisez l'énergie solaire que vous
concentrer sur un point chaud pour faire
une source chaude à votre centrale
donc au lieu de faire brûler du charbon
ou cassés des noyaux d'uranium en deux
et bien vous allez concentrer du
rayonnement solaire c'est ça votre
source chaude du coup chauffer un
réservoir de saumur et ce réservoir de
saumur si votre champ de miroirs est
suffisamment important il peut être
portés à une température suffisamment
élevé pour que ça permette de passer une
partie de la nuit
donc l'intérêt du solaire à
concentration par rapport au solaire
photovoltaïque c'est que ça vous
supprime pour partie la question de
quand ya pas de soleil je fais quoi
ce qui est un gros gros avantage dans la
gestion des réseaux oui
oui alors la source froide seller
ambiant donc le rendement est pas très
bon
c'est voilà c'est mais c'est pas très
grave parce que si vous êtes dans le
désert alors c'est grave pour la
consommation de matériaux parce que si
vous avez besoin de trois fois plus de
miroir vous avez besoin de trois fois
plus de verre de métal etc par
kilowattheure produit par contre c'est
pas pour être des espaces est-ce que
vous avez tout l'espace que vous voulez
donc c'est mais c'est un problème de
matériaux ça c'est clair je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure la france
vous avez ici une carte de l'insolation
en ce qui concerne le monde dans son
ensemble et donc vous voyez que les
endroits où c'est pertinent d'aller
mettre du solaire à concentration ou à
photovoltaïque c'est des endroits qui
sont cerclés en rouge
alors malheureusement ce que vous voyez
également c'est que à quelques
exceptions près en particulier la
californie parce que la californie est
un endroit qui efface un gros
consommateur d'électricité
vous vous rappelez peut-être qu'en
termes économiques si la californie
était un état indépendant se serait la
septième puissance économique mondiale
donc c'est quand même un gros un gros
paquet d'activités donc une grosse
consommation électrique mais à part la
californie l'essentiel des zones qui
sont très bien d'un sol et sont dans des
endroits il ya personne
donc si on utilise oui
il
je ne
je vous ai montré l'assèchement je vous
ai pas montré l'augmentation de
l'insolation
non non il n'y a pas l'assèchement en
fait il résulte de deux choses il
résulte d'une baisse de la pluviométrie
donc ça effectivement ça va diminuer
c'est ça vient d'une diminution de la
nébulosité globalement mais ça vient
aussi d'une augmentation de
l'évaporation et ça il n'y aura pas de
lien avec les nuages
donc ce que je vous ai montré la
dernière fois c'était l'assèchement du
pourtour du bassin méditerranéen
ce que vous voyez là donc encore une
fois c'est que les grandes zones
d'insolation sont loin des grandes zones
de consommation alors il ya des gens qui
ont imaginé que l'on pouvait installer
des batteries de centrales solaires
photovoltaïques à concentration dans ces
zones là puis tiré des grandes lignes
électriques qui irait dans jusque dans
les pays où les zones dans lesquelles on
consomme beaucoup d'électricité
c'est quelque chose qui est pas
complètement idiot
dans la mesure où après tout vous avez
bien des grandes lignes maritimes des
grandes lignes aériennes donc on
pourrait très bien faire des grandes
lignes électriques fait dire sur le fond
c'est pas c'est pas plus compliqué par
contre ça pose des questions
intéressantes d'accord de partage parce
qu'il est évident que si vous utilisez
le soleil des maliens si les maliens
sont big horn est normalement ils vont
pas vous laisser l'utiliser gratuitement
donc il ya une question de partage donc
dans l'idée des gens qui disent les
énergies renouvelables c'est une manière
de s'affranchir de la dépendance aux
autres bah c'est moins sympathique
monsieur empêche pas de le faire et
qu'est ce que je veux dire et en tout
état de cause c'est pas quelque chose
qu'il peut se faire
rapidement soit dit en passant sur les
matériaux qui sont nécessaires pour
faire des panneaux solaires on se rend
également extrêmement dépendant
aujourd'hui les dix premiers fabricants
de cellules photovoltaïques dans le
monde sont chinois les dix premiers on
parle le premier les trois prochains dix
premiers donc tous les plans de
développement du solaire en europe
typiquement sont des plans qui favorise
l'industrie chinoise on peut le faire si
on pense que c'est une bonne idée mais
ça c'est contrepartie le ici vous avez
quelque chose qui est intéressant sur
l'occupation de surface comparés entre
le solaire à concentration et
l'hydroélectricité
je vous avais parlé au moment du cours
sur le changement climatique parce qu'on
avait posé la question de l' influence
des émissions de vapeur d'eau d'origine
humaine dans les tours de
refroidissement je vous avais dit c'est
pas grand chose
par contre la vapeur d'eau qui vient du
barrage d'assouan ça c'est quelque chose
parce que le barrage d'assouan en est un
très très gros barrages en superficie au
regard de la zone dans laquelle il est
implanté et ça fait d évaporation
artificielle en l'occurrence de vapeur
d'eau sur toute cette surface qui est là
qui sont ça fait désirer par une
évaporation qui est loin d'être
négligeable et à lorsque comparé ce
graphique c'est la superficie qu'il
faudrait couvrir en miroir alors ça ça
ne demande de couvrir en béton que le
barrage lui-même après la nature fait le
reste
nature a fait la vallée val est remplie
tout seul là c'est quand même quelque
chose qu'il faudrait artificialisés nous
tout seul ça fait quand même la
superficie d'une grosse ville mais par
contre en terme d'occupation global
l'espace
ce que vous voyez c'est que c'est pas
quelque chose qui est totalement
délirant si on n'a pas de problème de
matériaux en fait
on a des problèmes de matériaux
évidemment si on veut commencer à
remplacer la totalité de l'électricité
qu'on consomme dans le monde part du
solaire à concentration ça sera toujours
le problème par contre ça a un avantage
sur le photovoltaïque c'est que le
photovoltaïque et de la production de
bout de réseau et de réseaux a pas été
fait pour ça le réseau est un système
qui a historiquement été fait pour être
un système descendants dont vous avez de
la production en tête de réseau à très
haut voltage et puis après c'est comme
vous perdez du voltage comme vous perdez
de l'altitude et donc vous avez
l'électricité qui est progressivement
distribués sur un nombre croissant de
zone et de consommateurs en or un
processus qui est un processus de
descente en tension et vous avez par
ailleurs une mutualisation
parce que si vous regardez je sais pas
si je vous l'avais déjà fait le calcul
si vous regardez la puissance que peut
soutirer en france la totalité des
appareils électriques installées c'est
quatre à cinq fois la puissance
électrique installée en production c'est
clair on répète la puissance installée
en production la puissance pilotable
installé en production est de l'ordre
d'une centaine de gigawatts
la puissance totale de tous les
appareils installés en france aux
aspirateurs ascenseur batteur la
mayonnaise laminoir train etc
c'est quelques centaines de giga watts
d'accord c'est cinq fois plus en gros
l'intérêt du réseau c'est que ça
mutualisent la production parce que bien
évidemment vous vous servez pas le
conducteur du train ont reconduit le
train il est pas en train de se servir
de son aspirateur chez lui donc vous
avez toutes les machines sont pas
utilisées en même temps et donc avec une
puissance plus réduite que la puissance
de la totalité des machines électriques
installés dans ce pays vous êtes quand
même capable de servir tout le monde
pareil cette mutualisation dans le rêve
risque ignan dans lequel chacun vit
heureux chez soi avec son panneau
solaire et sa batterie sans réseau à ce
moment vous êtes obligé de dimensionner
la puissance de pointe de toutes les
installations locales à la consommation
de pointe de toutes les installations
locales
c'est clair et donc à ce moment vous
êtes obligés d'installer quatre à cinq
fois plus de puissance dans le pays donc
le réseau est une source d'économie de
puissance installée
c'est à ça qu'il sert et c'est justement
parce que les pays qui se sont expliqués
il ya longtemps avec moins de moyens
qu'aujourd'hui qu'ils ont créé des
réseaux pour mutualiser les moyens
existants et pas avoir à les dupliquer
partout donc le solaire à concentration
il est intéressant parce qu'il est en
tête de réseau et donc ils bénéficient
de cet effet de mutualisation de la tête
de réseau versus le photovoltaïque qui
lui ne bénéficie pas de cet effet ce que
je suis en train de vous dire donc là en
indirect
c'est que l'autoconsommation
photovoltaïque
c'est à dire le fait que chacun est chez
soi de quoi consommer sa propre
électricité
contrairement à une idée couramment
répandue ça augmente très fortement les
investissements globaux dans un pays et
donc ça augmente très fortement le prix
coûte prix total de l'électricité dans
un pays et si vous avez quelqu'un qui
localement paye son électricité moins
chère grâce à ça c'est juste un effet de
passager clandestin
la surcharge sera reporté sur tous les
autres je vais vous le dire encore
autrement
comme nous avons en france un système
électrique qui est un système à coût
fixe puisque le nucléaire c'est des
coûts fixes et le réseau c'est des coûts
fixes si vous rajoutez des panneaux
solaires pour pas consommer
l'électricité du réseau quand vous avez
du soleil vous rajouter un troisième
système à coûts fixes par dessus de
systèmes à coût fixe donc le coût global
de l'ensemble augmente extrêmement
simple oui
et
un plafond de quoi
c'est pas intéressant de quel point de
vue c'est à dire que vous la question
c'est est ce que pour un surplus de
population ça vaut pas le coup que ce
surplus lui et son installation de son
côté anne ont alors plusieurs réseaux
mutualisés c'est une duplication
d'infrastructures c'est un seul réseau
qui est intéressant parce que comme ça
vous fait communiquer tous les
consommateurs et tous les a tous les
outils de production ensemble donc c'est
là que vous avez l'effet de
mutualisation plus important après si
vous rajoutez si vous dites les
conservateurs supplémentaires je les
laisse au réseau ils ont qu'à s'équiper
chez eux
en fait il est là voulait priver
globalement de l'électricité marginal
que le réseau pourrait leur fournir
enfin le réseau et les appareils de
production du réseau pourrait leur
fournir
et c'est beaucoup moins cher c'est
électricité marginal que le coût complet
de production d'une installation
autonome
on y vient après dans tous les cas de
figure quand vous avez un réseau vous
avez intérêt à vous en servir
je voulais dit tout à l'heure
oui
le réseau est un système bayer ses
toiles d'araignée en raw et donc vous
mettez à n'importe quel point de la
toile soit un conservateur soit un
dispositif de production non il est
partiellement en étoile mais vous avez
également des il est partiellement aussi
entre l'araignée quand vous quand il est
purement en étoile vous êtes dans ce
qu'on appelle des presqu'île électrique
typiquement la bretagne ou le sud-est de
la france est le gestionnaire du réseau
à2pas ça je peux vous dire il aime bien
avoir la redondance
je
en quoi c'est un problème pardon alors
attendez quand je dis en tête de réseau
je parlais du voltage je parlais pas
d'une position géographique cirque le
réseau en france c'est un paquebot et
d'un squelette à 400 kilovolts en
dessous un réseau moyenne tension entre
20 et 80 mille volts est encore en
dessous un réseau de distribution à 220
volts
enfin 380 triphasé encore les têtes de
réseaux je voulais dire des
installations de production qui sont
branchés sur la partie à 400 kilovolts
c'est ça que je voulais dire que la
centrale soit à gardanne où à gravelines
c'est pas le sujet c'est cette dette sur
le réseau à 400 kilovolts
parce que quand vous regardez quand vous
faites de rapide calcul vous vous rendez
compte que la déperdition électrique à
ces tensions la à 400 kilovolts pour
aller d'un boutade de la france ces
quelques pourcents les 2% à 3%
du coup vous pouvez mettre votre
centrale pour vous voulez pourvu que
vous ayez la capacité de transport
[Rires]
je voulais dit tout à l'heure donc un
deuxième effet du soleil c'est qu'il
évapore l'eau et donc il l'a fait
précipiter ce cycle de l'eau est à
l'origine de l'exploitation de la
première électricité d'origine
renouvelable que nous ayons en
importance qui est donc
l'hydroélectricité alors
l'hydroélectricité dans son principe
c'est extrêmement simple
c'est là le perfectionnement des moulins
à eau vous avez
une énergie potentielle de chute qui est
la masse fois la constante d'attraction
fois la hauteur et donc ce que vous
allez récupérer quand vous turbines et
de l'eau c'est exactement ça c'est à
dire c'est cette énergie potentielle qui
devient d'énergie cinétique
quand vous ouvrez la vanne fois un
coefficient de pertes qui est dû au fait
que vous avez un peu de flottement
vous avez un peu de frottement dans la
canalisation qui va du barrage vers la
turbine et vous avez un peu de
frottement sur la turbine and men alors
question combien on peut en faire
oui non non non non c'est le rendement
total dans le rhône mamba c'est
mécanique donc en fait dès que vous avez
un et inversement le rendement du moteur
électrique est très bon aussi
donc le
la transmission mécanique de l'eau aux
élèves de la turbine un très bon
coefficient est par ailleurs la
transformation du mouvement en
électricité un très bon coefficient
aussi alors la question c'est combien on
peut en faire
ici vous avez un petit calcul théorique
pour l'europe justement puisque la
question m'a été posée tout à l'heure en
gros de l'e3 électricité vous pouvez en
faire facilement là où mère nature fait
tomber l'eau en altitude et que vous
pouvez assez facilement cette eau qui
tombe en altitude la collecter en
altitude faire une canalisation qui
descend beaucoup plus bas et la turbine
est beaucoup plus bas donc le seul
endroit de relief qui vous offre cette
opportunité ça s'appelle des montagnes
donc les montagnes qu'est ce qu'elle
vous permettent de faire elles ont
dévalé suspendu c'est à dire des vallées
que vous pouvez fermer en altitude
l'eau qui ruisselle dans ces vallées que
ce soit de l'eau de fonte de glaciers de
l'eau de fonte de neige ou de la pluie
vous la collecter ça s'appelle un
barrage et du barrage vous faites
descendre ou pas du rsa dépendre que
vous avez mis le barrage mais du barrage
vous faites descendre un tuyau en bas
deux vallées et pour avoir la plus haute
hauteur de chute possibles et en basse
vallée vous turbine lots en c'est juste
un jet d'eau qui va actionner une
turbine de temps en temps vous n'avez
pas de grande hauteur de chute par
exemple pour ceux d'entre vous qui
connaissent le barrage de serre ponçon
acer consent vous n'avez pas de hauteur
de chute
vous avez juste la hauteur d'eau du
barrage parce que la turbine est au pied
du vous n'avez pas de dénivellation à
laval alors question combien est-ce
qu'on peut en avoir de cette affaire
donc ici j'ai regardé un certain nombre
de massifs montagneux que vous avez en
en europe pour chacun d'entre eux j'ai
regardé leur superficie et leur hauteur
moyenne au-dessus des vallées d'accord
donc ça vous donne une fois que vous
avez le nombre de millimètres de pluie
par an soit la superficie vous avez le
volume d'eau qui tombe et une fois que
vous avez la hauteur
de là où sa tombe par rapport au fond de
vallée vous avez la hauteur de chute
donc là vous avez la masse d'eau tombés
en altitude fois la hauteur de chute il
ya plus qu'à rajouter j'ai qui est l'âme
inquiète même chez tout le monde et ça
vous donne le potentiel théorique qui
peuvent venir de l'hydroélectricité
quand c'est très simple le calcul de
grandeur est très simple est ce que vous
constatez c'est que si on regarde le
voilà est donc là après vous avez le
le rendement on va dire qui s'applique
aujourd'hui en europe
l'hydroélectricité représente un peu
moins de 1000 térawattheures c'est entre
500 et 1000 je me rappelle plus
exactement la quantité
donc vous voyez qu'on n'est pas très
très loin du maximum théorique de ce
qu'on peut faire on a équipé l'essentiel
des montagnes suédoise norvégienne dans
les alpes etc
on peut plus on peut plus faire grand
chose ce qu'on peut encore faire c'est
des bassins de rétention artificiel par
exemple je me suis amusé un jour à faire
un petit calcul théorique sur la
quantité d'eau qu'il faudrait qu'on paie
au dessus du léman si on voulait stocker
de cette manière les énergies
intermittentes des éoliennes ou des
panneaux solaires
donc vous pouvez imaginer noyer toutes
les vallées qui sont au dessus du léman
l'a donc pour tous les gens qui aiment
bien les faire du ski dans les stations
qui sont juste au sud du léman vous
oubliez ya plus de balles et les
prestations ont fait des barrages
partout mais ça peut pomper l'eau du
léman est compensée l'intermittence des
éoliennes mais si on sait le seul genre
de truc que vous pouvez faire
aujourd'hui c'est à dire l'autre pluie
qui tombe naturellement on a à peu près
tout tout tout évacuer tout le consomme
alors l'hydroélectricité en fait tout le
monde a en tête le barrage que je viens
d'évoquer
mais j'ai été incomplet dans mais un
stade dans mes explications parce qu'il
ya une deuxième source de production
électrique qui est importante qui est ce
qu'on appelle l'électricité au fil de
l'eau alors là c'est l'exact inverse du
barrage qui est beaucoup de puissance
puisque vous avez une forte hauteur de
chute est pas la possibilité d'assurer
de la production toute l'année parce que
sinon le lac de barrage se viderait
rapidement le fil de l'eau c'est l'exact
inverse
c'est une dérivation d'un fleuve une
faible hauteur de chute et ça tourne
toute l'année alors en fait ça tourne
toute l'année plus ou moins fortement
je vais vous donner un exemple
vous savez que quand on parle du débit
du rhône
on parle du débit d'un fleuve qui
l'hiver pardon au printemps se baladent
à presque mille mètres cubes à la
seconde à certains endroits mais l'été
ça peut être dix fois moins 1 était un
peu sec vous souvenez peut-être que
l'année dernière le doubs a été
totalement à sec sur une partie de son
be
donc le donc le débit même d'un barrage
au fil de l'eau et bien vous pouvez
avoir une production quand même l'été
qui est significativement inférieure à
ce qu'elle est au printemps ou à
l'automne
et puis de l'autre côté vous avez les
barrages qui servent à faire de la
régulation de pointe et donc là dedans
vous allez trouver ce qu'on appelle les
éclusées et les barrages de haute chute
alors les écluses et c'est des barrages
de petites chutes
en fait c'est juste ça la différence
donc c'est des barrages avec un
réservoir donc une retenue simplement
vous n'avez pas une grande hauteur de
chute derrière la retenue alors que les
barrages de ochun typiquement
grandmaison
c'est un barrage de haute chute serre
ponçon et pour le mans dans les écluses
et une fois que je vous ai dit ça la
question c'est quelle est la fraction de
l'hydroélectricité dans
l'approvisionnement électrique des pays
aujourd'hui alors ce que vous voyez
oui
non enfin oui au sens de à partir du
moment où il faut que vous fassiez un
kilomètre pour avoir dix mètres de
hauteur de chute
et bien si vous avez 300 km2 fleuve vous
pouvez mettre 300 300 barrage au fil de
l'eau donc ça fait beaucoup mais ça fait
que ça est par ailleurs sur 10 mètres de
hauteur de chute vous allez quand même
avoir beaucoup moins que sur 2000 m
comme vous pouvez avoir dans les alpes
dernier point le fleuve sert aussi pour
la navigation
ça vous aura pas échappé de temps en
temps le fleuve c'est du reste ça
certainement pour la délégation que là
aussi dans les conséquences de la
sécheresse de l'été dernier vous avez le
rhin qui s'est tellement asséché l'été
dernier fall le bassin versant du rhin
c'est tellement à sécher et le niveau du
rein est devenu tellement bas que une
partie des transports de marchandises
qui permet à l'industrie allemande de
tournai et même à certaines centrales à
charbon tournée nouvelles de mon point
de vue les transports n'ont pas pu avoir
lieu parce qu'il y avait plus assez
d'eau dans fleuve une partie de
l'industrie allemande a tourné au
ralenti à la fin de l'année dernière et
ça explique peut-être la petite
récession qu'a connue l'allemagne sur le
dernier trimestre de l'année 2018 donc
le donc les barrages au fil de l'eau
vous avez un vous avez un nombre limite
liée au fait que la hauteur de chute du
fleuve entre son embouchure et le début
de l'endroit où vous mettez des barrages
au fil de l'eau aussi d'éviter quoi donc
ici vous voyez le la part de
l'hydroélectricité dans le
dans l'approvisionnement électrique d'un
certain nombre de pays bric le champion
mondial toutes catégories en proportion
si la norvège qui est aussi le premier
producteur européen en valeur absolue de
térawattheures hydroélectrique de
mémoire à norvégien consomme trois fois
plus d'électricité qu'un français ça
doit être dans ces eaux là
voilà la france et pas très loin de la
moyenne européenne
vous voyez à 10% enfin à peu près à peu
près 10% et vous voyez également qu' il
ya des il ya des continents qui sont
mieux lotis que d'autres et en
particulier l'amérique du sud est très
bien lotis parce que vous avez beaucoup
de montagne la cordillère des andes
beaucoup de flotte il tombe beaucoup de
pluie à l'équateur et donc vous avez la
possibilité de mettre beaucoup de marge
alors en europe vous le disais tout à
l'heure les barrages on a un peu mangé
notre pain blanc au sens de on a
installé à peu près tout ce qu'on
pouvait installer c'est pas aussi simple
que ça ailleurs dans le monde on ne sait
pas aussi vrai ailleurs dans le monde
ici vous avez un
un graphique qui vous représente pour
chaque zone ce qui a été équipé ce qui
est encore envisageable
techniquement prendre économiquement est
ce qui pourra l'être techniquement si on
se fout du prix est ce que vous voyez
donc pour l'europe tout à droite c'est
que ces chevaux disais tout à l'heure de
mémoire on est à 6 100 térawattheures
d'électricité produite aujourd'hui le
petit calcul théorique que je vous ai
fait tout à l'heure c'est que si je
prends toute la flotte qui tombe sur
toutes les montagnes en est plutôt
habile de sang vous voyez ça correspond
à peu près au fait que la moitié est
équipé mais si je ne prends que ce qui
est économiquement considérés comme
pertinents aujourd'hui on est plutôt aux
deux tiers ou autres car c'est en asie
en gros que vous avez le plus gros
potentiel de barrages restants à 1
restant à construire alors retenez
également une chose importante c'est que
l'essentiel des barrages dans le monde
là je parle bien des barrages ne servent
pas à produire de l'électricité
ils servent à quoi
la variation absolument ça sert à faire
des retenues d'eau pour l'irrigation
alors en france vous avez soit dit en
passant
aussi cet usage parfois sur certaines
retenues d'eau ce qui veut dire que
quand vous avez et vous avez un
également des lacs de barrage qui sert
pour le tourisme par exemple sur le
barrage de serre ponçon il ya une école
de voile de mémoire ce qui veut dire que
vous pouvez commencer à avoir avec les
retenues de barrages des conflits
d'usagé c'est-à-dire que les indices
turbine et moi l'eau pour avoir de
l'électricité sans carbone les autres 10
98 en guinée palau parce que je la
gardais pour l'irrigation et les
troisièmes 19 fait ni l'un ni l'autre
parce que je veux pouvoir faire de la
voile sur le lac de barrage
donc vous avez des conflits d'usagé qui
peuvent apparaître avec les retenues
d'eau et notamment entre l'agriculture
et
la production hydroélectrique ah pardon
et j'oubliais un dernier conflit d'usagé
qui est de soutenir les débits d'étiage
puisque à la fois pour des raisons de
production des centrales nucléaires en
france de refroidissement donc mais
aussi pour des raisons écologiques parce
qu'il faut que les poissons et encore un
peu d'eau pour survivre dans les fleuves
vous avez également des lâchers d'eau
dans les barrages qui ont pour principal
déterminant le fait de soutenir le débit
d'étiage et qui reste de l'eau dans le
fleuve
donc vous avez donc les barrages peuvent
avoir des usages qui sont variés voici
un lac de barrage
il s'agit du barrage de vachon en
garonne en italie qui à la fin des
années 50 au début des années 60 je me
souviens jamais a connu un accident il
ya eu des pluies diluviennes et une
partie de la montagne qui était situé
vous voyez bien là que ça s'est détachée
là donc c'est comme la face des drus
mais sauf que c'est pas d'être venu donc
une partie de la montagne s'est détaché
a fait un énorme glissement de terrain
qui est rentré dans le lac de barrage du
coup le lac de barrage à déborder toute
la flotte est passé par dessus le mur de
barrage a dévalé la vallée très
encaissée qui était à laval et ça a fait
plus de 2000 morts
vous avez également en france la rupture
du barrage de fréjus malpasset alors
qu'il lui était une retenue d'eau à
usage agricole qui a également fait plus
de 400 morts
et enfin l'installation la plus
meurtrière
enfin le l'accident d'install à 2-2
d'unités de production électrique qui a
fait le plus de morts dans le monde dans
l'instantané c'est ben non c'est pas
tchernobyl sinon je poserai pas la
question c'est pas drôle c'est un
barrage
c'est le barrage de banqiao en chine qui
au milieu des années 70 et on voir star
complexe de barrages qui s'est rompue
également à la suite de pluies
diluviennes et alors évidemment les
statistiques sont pas fiables mais qui a
fait n'importe quoi entre 20 et 100
mille morts là dans une partie des gens
sont morts de la vague de crues et
beaucoup d'autres sont morts parce que
comme les voies de communication étaient
coupées
et vous aviez de l'eau croupie partout
où ils sont morts du choléra voilà donc
les barrages
contrairement à une idée reçue c'est pas
des installations complètement anodine
et une blague que je fais souvent c'est
si on donne le choix entre habitait près
d'une centrale nucléaire et à l'aval
d'un barrage je choisis près de la
centrale nucléaire sans hésiter l'aval
du barrage ça a fait beaucoup plus de
morts dans le monde
historiquement alors maintenant on va
s'intéresser à la biomasse
à alors oui vous avez également avec les
barrages c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure mais j'en ai parlé au moment où
je parlais de remonter l'eau du léman on
peut faire des uns des stations de
pompage donc la station de pompage c'est
un barrage réversible les stations de
pompage c'est des barrages réversible
c'est à dire que vous avez à la fois une
turbine qui permet de turbines et l'eau
en provenance de la retenue et une pompe
pardon et quand l'eau a été turbiner au
lieu de la laisser repartir dans le
fleuve ou dans la rivière vous la mettez
dans une retenue à la valeur et quand
vous avez d'électricité en trop sur le
réseau ou fait le chemin inverse c'est à
dire qu'avec une pompe vous prenez le de
la retenue à vallet vous la remettez
dans la retenue avant et cette
installation là s'appelle une station de
pompage et en france on en a cinq
gigawatts de stations de pompage
sachant que la puissance installée ces
100 gigawatts alors mais c'est des
installations qui permettent de faire 2
2 comment dire de récupérer un peu
d'électricité patent et de fournir un
peu d'électricité
pas tant parce que en termes de fraction
de la consommation quotidienne que ça
permet c'est une toute petite partie
donc je disais maintenant on va
s'arrêter
10 grammes de co2 au kilomètre heure le
olic
il y a
alors ça dépend si on parle de la durée
de vie du mur du barrage qui normalement
est raisonnablement éternelle parce que
sinon les gens qui sont à laval en du
social faire ou si on parle de sa durée
de fonctionnement normal et alors en
fait si effectivement on ne purge pas ce
qui se passe c'est que quand l'eau qui
ruisselle à la bombe notamment en
montagne arrive dans le barrage elle est
chargée de sédiments et donc vous avez
exactement comme la sédimentation près
des côtes dans les océans vous avez une
sédimentation au fond du lac de barrage
qui se fait donc si vous purgée par
intervalles réguliers pour enlever la
boue vous avez henrot font effectivement
au bout d'un moment vous pouvez plus
vous en servir vous pouvez plus vous
servir du barrage comme d'un lac de
retenue après vous pouvez toujours vous
en servir comme de l'installation au fil
de l'eau mais plus comme d'un lac de
retenue absolument mais serge et poser
exactement la même question aux gens ddf
est la réponse qui m'a été fait a jamais
été une réponse du genre au bout de 80
ans vous pouvez plus vous en servir je
crois que c'est très très dépendant de
la façon dont vous l'entretenez
donc la biomasse ici vous voyez que sur
ce petit graphique que je vous avais
montré sur le cycle du carbone
vous avez 120 milliards de tonnes de
carbone qui sont chaque année séquestrés
par les écosystèmes terrestres sous
forme de photosynthèse
alors ces écosystèmes terrestres respire
dans le même temps ou plus exactement
même les arbres respire donc les donc
les arbres respire exactement comme les
animaux mignons ils ont un processus
d'oxydation est donc ce qu'on appelle la
productivité primaires nets c'est à dire
ce qui est séquestré par la
photosynthèse
- ce qui est respiré par les plantes ça
représente 60 milliards de tonnes de
carbone par an alors comme le pétrole et
le charbon c'est essentiellement du
carbone 60 milliards de tonnes de
carbone séquestré par la biomasse
ça veut dire que en contenu énergétique
ces 60 milliards de tonnes équivalent
pétrole en ordre de grandeur un ordre de
grandeur la consommation actuelle de
l'humanité c'est 14 donc il ya plein de
gens qui disent
miam miam il ya tout ce qu'il faut dans
la biomasse pour qu'on puisse substituer
tous nos usages énergétiques
la réalité est un peu plus compliqué que
ça parce que d'abord une bonne partie de
cette biomasse c'est pas idiot auquel
reste là où elle est parce que ça
s'appelle des écosystèmes ensuite une
bonne partie de cette photosynthèse
elle sert à faire pousser des choses que
nous mangeons donc le contenu et le
convertisseur s'est noué le contenu
énergétique c'est ce qu'on mange donc ça
normalement c'est pas disponible pour
faire fonctionner des convertisseurs
extracorporelle c'est à dire des
machines
donc en fait quand vous regardez la
fraction de cette biomasse qui est
disponible pour l' usage des hommes
vous avez sûrement pas 60 milliards de
tonnes équivalent pétrole par an mais
vous pourriez quand même en avoir
quelques milliards de tonnes
ça c'est pas complètement déraisonnables
une première manière
donc après cette biomasse il ya plein de
manières de s'en servir
vous pouvez comme je le disais tout à
l'heure vous servir directement du bois
ils voulaient ou directement de ce qu'il
brûle et le brûler vous pouvez en faire
des agrocarburants on va rapidement
regarder en quoi ça consiste
et vous pouvez en faire du biogaz j'en
ai parlé rapidement tout à l'heure donc
en gros vous en faites des combustibles
solides liquides ou gazeux exactement
comme avec les combustibles fossiles et
qui ont en gros à peu près les mêmes
usages c'est à dire qu'avec le bois vous
pouvez faire de la chaleur domestiques
ou de la chaleur industrielle
exactement comme avec le charbon ou de
l'électricité exactement comme avec le
charbon les rendements sont moins bons
pourquoi est ce que les rendements sont
moins bons avec le bois
non c'est beaucoup plus bête que ça
exactement c'est à cause c'est la faute
monsieur carnaval c'est parce que la
température de combustion du bois est
plus basse que la température de
combustion du charbon
juste ça donc les rendements sont moins
bons mais donc on peut utiliser du bois
en substitut du charbon encore une fois
dans tout un tas de trucs
les cimenteries ou les centrales
électriques on peut utiliser des
agrocarburants substitut des 40 des
combustibles liquides donc les voitures
les avions etc
le monde aérien ne rêvent que de ça bref
de faire voler tous les avions de la
planète avec des inrocks à blanc alors
je vous donne tout de suite le résultat
je reviendrai après j'en doute sans
doute parce qu'aujourd'hui le kérosène
c'est 10% du pétrole qu'on consomme sur
terre si je transforme toutes les
céréales que nous produisons sur terre
en agrocarburants ça me fait un quart du
pétrole qu'on consomme donc il faudrait
que les avionneurs enfin que les
compagnies aériennes car à elle seule la
moitié de la production céréalière
mondiale transformer en agrocarburants
pour faire voler tous les avions du
monde aux avions pour hoarau garbure en
suis pas complètement sûr de parier sur
le fait que ça va marcher et vous pouvez
en faire des combustibles gazeux des
combustibles gazeux j'en ai parlé tout à
l'heure donc c'est un substitut au gaz
naturel et vous pouvez à nouveau en
faire de l'électricité de la chaleur ou
du carburant
voilà la version combustibles solides
vous avez là évidemment des rendements
qui sont bons puisque c'est les
rendements de transmission de combustion
à de la chaleur
si par contre vous allez dans
l'électricité vous êtes plutôt à 20 % de
rendement donc c'est les rendements qui
sont pas bon pas bon du tout ensuite
vous pouvez en faire des combustibles
liquides
si vous en faites des combustibles
liquides en fait vous allez pas pouvoir
faire des agrocarburants on va dire de
façon simple la première filière pour
faire des agrocarburants c'est une
filière qui consiste à produire des
choses qui peuvent se transformer en
éthanol par fermentation donc c'est soit
de la vie dont des céréales soit du
sucre de betterave ou la can vous donner
ça à manger à des petites bactéries les
petites bactéries vont vous faire un jus
sucre et le jus de fermentation c'est
exactement comme le vin même principe
est exactement comme le vin vous avez un
mélange d'eau et d'alcool vous devez
séparer les deux donc vous allez devoir
distillés et le gros problème du
processus de production du bioéthanol
c'est exactement suis là c'est que vous
avez une opération de distillation dont
vous avez une opération qui demande de
consommer beaucoup de chaleur et donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
rendement à l'arrivée est pas bon du
tout vous avez à un deuxième processus
de production d'agrocarburants qui lui
passe par des oléagineux donc à ce
moment vous allez faire un substitut au
diesel et non pas à l'essence avec des
plantes oléagineuses donc typiquement du
thon de sol du soja etc des arachides en
fait ce que vous voulez hélas le
processus d'extraction lui est purement
mécanique
par exemple la graine de tournesol vous
vous contentez de l'écraser quand vous
n'avez pas besoin de grandes quantités
de chaleur et donc le rendement de
transformation est bien meilleure par
contre le rendement de production et
plus mauvais c'est à dire qu'avec des
betteraves
vous avez plusieurs dizaines de tonnes
de betteraves à l'hectare quand vous les
cultiver alors qu'avec des oléagineux
vous avez de mémoire quelques tonnes à
l'hectare
de graines de tournesol ou de graines de
soja ou de graines de colza donc le
rendement de culture et beaucoup moins
bon par contre derrière le rendement de
rendement de production est bien
meilleure question c'est quoi le bilan
carbone de cette affaire
la question est compliquée parce que
quand vous produisez des agrocarburants
en fait vous ne produisez pas que des
agrocarburants vous produisez ça et
d'autres choses
quand vous produisez quand vous faites
de l'éthanol en pratique vous allez
avoir plusieurs manières de ou des
choses vous pouvez affectés selon la
basse vous pouvez affectés selon la
valeur économique
vous pouvez affectés selon l'énergie de
transformation qui a été nécessaire
enfin bref vous avez plusieurs règles et
en fonction de la rai que vous utilisez
vous n'avez pas le même résultat alors
prenons l'exemple de l'éthanol l'éthanol
consiste à faire des cultures la culture
vous produit du grain et de la paille
question est-ce que vous affecter une
partie des intrants la culture la paille
ou pas ensuite une fois que vous allez
faire votre fermentation ou betteraves
c'est pareil
une fois que vous allez faire votre
fermentation vous allez obtenir un juge
sucré est-ce que vous affecter une
partie des intrants à l'eau ou pas au
co2 qui s'échappe au pas et c est donc
en fonction de la méthode que vous
utilisez vous avez des résultats très
différents
vous avez également des coproduits les
coproduits par exemple en ce qui
concerne l'éthanol c'est des drêches de
betteraves donc c'est des résidus
végétaux que vous avez une fois que vous
avez presevo betteraves ça sert en
alimentation animale est ce que vous le
valoriser au contenu énergétique parce
que c'est un contenu énergétique sinon
ça serait ça n'aurait aucun intérêt en
alimentation animale est ce que vous le
valoriser à la valeur économique versus
celle de l'éthanol ou est ce que vous
dites c'est en déchet parce que j'ai pas
fait de l'éthanol pour avoir des drèches
s'est juste fait de l'éthanol pour avoir
de l'éthanol et donc ça vaut zéro donc
en fonction de la de la méthode que vous
utilisez vous n'avez pas le même
résultat est ici voilà je je m'étends
pas longuement parce que c'est juste
pour vous faire comprendre
vous avez le gain que vous avez à la
fois en co2 et en énergie par rapport
un litre de pétrole ordinaire selon la
méthode que vous utilisez et vous voyez
que entre la méthode la plus favorable
est la méthode la plus défavorable et
bien dans un cas de figure vous avez
quasiment 60% d'économie à la fois en
co2 et en contenu fossiles par rapport à
un livre de pétrole ordinaire et avec la
plus mauvaise des méthodes que vous
pouvez utiliser ou la plus défavorable
vous n'avez que 10%
dit autrement vous n'êtes pas loin du un
point aux états unis une des raisons
d'avoir développé massivement l'éthanol
à partir de maïs c'est que comme la
distillation est faite avec du gaz et du
charbon qui sont en abondance chez eux
alors qu'ils sont importateurs de
pétrole
eh bien ça permet d'utiliser une énergie
domestique pour alimenter les voitures
en substitution d'une énergie importées
alors même que le rendement est pas très
loin de 20 points d'accord et je
rappelle encore une fois que les états
unis utilisent 40% de leur maïs pour
faire de l'éthanol le potentiel de cette
affaire donc j'y reviens alors
maintenant je vais prendre la france
donc vous voyez que l'insolation moyenne
de la france c'est allez on va dire
mille 500 kilowattheures par mètre carré
en moyenne
le rendement de la photosynthèse à 21
j'aurais pas dû l'affiché rentrer vous
posez la question c'est moins d'un pour
cent dit autrement l'énergie qui va être
contenue dans le glucose que la plante
va synthétiser à partir de l'énergie
solaire
c'est moins de 1 % de l'énergie solaire
reçue par la plante au cours de l'année
donc ce n'est pas très très bon le
rendement de la photosynthèse
en france nous avons donc
allez on va dire donc là ça vous donne
le calcul de la quantité d'énergie que
ça ça permet d'avoir et en france nous
avons 55 millions d'hectares donc vous
voyez si on a une substitution aux
carburants avec des processus de
production d'agrocarburants qui opine
tonnes équivalent pétrole à l'hectare
pourrait faire l'équivalent de 55
millions de tonnes de pétrole
je vous rappelle qu'aujourd'hui rien que
du pétrole on en consomme en france 75
millions de tonnes oui
est-ce qu'on peut augmenter la
photosynthèse
alors avec les espèces végétales
actuelle pas tant que ça parce que la
fourchette que je vous ai montré la
règle aube allemand
par contre vous avez des espèces en
particulier les algues qui peuvent
croître plus vite à la même qu'avec la
même quantité d'énergie solaire mais par
contre vous avez pas la surface pour les
faire pousser parce que vous allez
parcourir la moitié de la france de salé
et si vous voulez utiliser des bassins
d'eau salée flottant qui représente un
tiers de la superficie de la france ça
va quand même faire beaucoup
voilà donc vous êtes quand même
fortement limité à la base par le fait
que la photosynthèse est une petite
fraction de l'énergie solaire reçue et
donc vous voyez bien que dans un pays
dans lequel on utilise 240 millions de
tonnes équivalent pétrole d'énergie
primaire c'est ça la consommation de la
france
même en utilisant du bois en direct je
suis limité et on ne mange en plus
évidemment je suis limité à 100 à 150
150 métaux si je continue à manger et
donc j'utilise que le quart de la
superficie française qui est constitué
de forêts eh bien j'ai le quart de cette
valeur donc je suis plutôt aux alentours
de 30 ce qui est en gros ce qu'on
utilise aujourd'hui en provenance de la
biomasse dans le pays n'en a pas moins
on m'utilise invoqué me voyez donc on a
un petit potentiel d'augmentation mais
c'est pas comme si ça allait remplacer
la totalité de ce qu'on utilise par
ailleurs dans la chaleur bon dix minutes
pas une de plus et on se retrouve ici
alors après de la biomasse on va
regarder la géothermie profonde la
géothermie parfum la géothermie à
commencer par la géothermie profonde
donc la géothermie c'est une machine de
la géothermie profonde ça se voit
également comme une machine de carnot
pour faire de l'électricité
le principe est toujours le même vous
avez une sensation d'une source froide
est ce qui vous fait la source chaude
c'est un puits d'injection dans lequel
vous injecter de l'eau qui dans le sous
sol très chaud se transforme en eau très
chaude sous pression qui remonte par des
puits de récupération et ça vous fait
votre source chaude alors c'est quelque
chose qui marche bien là où vous avez de
la grande quantité de chaleur dans les
tréfonds du sol et donc dans les zones
volcaniques
c'est à dire là où vous avez des failles
vous pouvez aller chercher delà de la
chaleur il ya un problème technique non
négligeable lié à l'exploitation de
cette technologie qui est que comme
c'est un circuit ouvert dans le sous sol
au moment où l'eau circule dans le sous
sol elle se chargeant toutes les
cochonneries oxydantes qu'elle peut
trouver à cet endroit là et donc l'eau
qui remonte et chargé en tout un tas de
trucs et c'est elle est très corrosive
et donc c'est un des problèmes qui a en
général c'est que les installations ont
besoin d'être blindés contre la
corrosion de ce qui remonte du sous sol
vous avez une version intermédiaire qui
sert à chauffer la maison de radio
france pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
savent pas qui est d'aller pomper de la
chaleur dans une nappe intermédiaire
cette fois ci pour faire du chauffage
urbain dans la note du dogger sous l'île
de france est donc là c'est toujours
pareil vous allez chercher de l'eau
chaude mais vous en servez pas pour
faire de l'électricité s'est pas assez
chaud toute façon ça devait à 80 degrés
et enfin la troisième manière de se
servir de l'âge de ce qu'on appelle la
géothermie en fait c'est des pompes à
chaleur et les pompes à chaleur servent
à vous extraire des calories soit de
l'air soit de l'eau
donc le principe est toujours le même en
fait c'est un frigo inverser une pompe à
chaleur donc un frigo voyez bien ce que
c'est ça vous refroidit l'intérieur du
frigo ça vous choque l'extérieur eh bien
là c'est un frigo que vous mettez sur
l'extérieur et donc il vous refroidit
l'extérieur et ou chauffe intérieur soit
vous avez une pompe qu'on appelle aux
eaux
c'est à dire que le circuit qui va
chercher les calories à l'extérieur
celle d'un circuit d'eau il va chercher
les calories dans le sol et il les
transferts dans le logement soit et là
vous avez un circuit de chauffage
central une boucle d'eau chaude soit ça
va chercher les calories dans l'air et
ça les transferts à un circuit une
boucle d'eau chaude dans l'intérieur du
logement et à ce moment ça s'appelle air
ou si c'est simplement un appareil à air
conditionné réversible que vous avez
dans un certain nombre d'endroits à ce
moment ça s'appelle une pac air/air donc
là simplement ça va chercher les
calories dans l'air et s'avoue l'école
dans l'air ça ça ne marche évidemment
que sur une seule pièce
alors que les pac air eau elles peuvent
servir de chauffage central est ensuite
distribuée la chaleur via un réseau de
chauffage central maintenant on va
parler du vent alors le vent c'est la
deuxième grande 1ère très en vogue que
vous avez en ce moment le vent est dû à
des différences de pression
atmosphérique que vous pouvez avoir soit
de façon chronique avec des grandes
circulation par exemple les alizés soit
de façon conjoncturelle voire très
conjoncturel typiquement les thermiques
pour ceux d'entre vous qui font du
bateau quand vous regardez la carte des
vents en france ou en europe
ce que vous constatez c'est qu'il ya
deux grandes zones en france où il ya
pas mal de vent c'est le couloir
rhodanien et la façade atlantique et
plus largement en europe
vous voyez vous avez le golfe du lion et
le
la façade atlantique et en particulier
le nord de la façade atlantique pour
récupérer l'énergie du vent et bien on
fait un moulin à vent
donc ça s'appelle une éolienne et les
éoliennes ont une puissance qui dépend
de la section efficace c'est-à-dire de
la section qu'il va être couverte par
les pales de l'éolienne
par ailleurs la puissance étant le carré
de la masse par la vitesse étant pardon
la moitié car il a vraiment mal la
moitié de la masse fois la vitesse au
carré que divise le temps en fait vous
vous rendez compte que cette affaire-là
est une fonction du cube de la vitesse
du vent donc la puissance d'une éolienne
varient comme le cube de la puissance du
vent de la vitesse du vent je vais y
arriver
décidément et donc c'est quelque chose
qui est rapidement variable au cours du
temps vous pouvez avoir des grandes
variations de puissance par exemple avec
le parc installé en france après le
passage de la tempête big wave est bien
la puissance injectée sur le réseau est
passé de 10 gigawatts à moins de 1
gigawatt
en l'espace d'une journée donc on a dit
on à diminuer la puissance injectés par
les éoliennes de 9 gigawatts
comme les journalistes alors compté en
centrale nucléaire ça fait neuf
centrales nucléaires voilà en l'espace
d'une journée donc ça fait quand même
des grandes variations le on envisage de
également maintenant de mettre des
éoliennes flottantes
alors pourquoi ce qu'on a envie de
mettre les éoliennes sur la mer parce
que sur la mer vous avez moins de
résistance au vent et donc vous avez des
vents qui sont plus réguliers et donc
vous avez une production annuelle qui
est plus importante par contre vous avez
des coûts qui augmentent fortement parce
que à terre va vous mettez vous planter
directement les éoliennes dans la terre
plus vous allez en mer et plus vous avez
besoin d'une infrastructure sous marine
qui est importante et si vous avez une
éolienne flottante vous avez besoin
d'une infrastructure sous marine qui est
encore plus importante parce qu'il faut
faire une grande plate-forme d'ancrage
des câbles etc
l'éolienne comme elle vous produits
comme le solaire soit dit en passant une
électricité qui arrive quand les
conditions le déterminer non pas quand
vous en avez besoin
elle va mordre sur votre production dite
de base donc la production de base dans
un pays c'est celle qui tourne tout le
temps c'est la production dont vous avez
besoin tout le temps ici vous avez une
semaine typique d'hiver en france
eh bien vous voyez la base c'est tout ce
qui se trouve sous le creux
c'est ce que vous allez avoir
l'influencé de la sni va aussi parce que
là bas c'est plutôt annuel donc c'est ce
que vous avez absolument toute l'année
mais disons que là est ce que vous avez
sur une semaine vous voyez ça s'arrête
là et donc pour assurer le surplus qui
va au dessus il faut des moyens qu'ils
soient pilotable parce que vous avez
deux pointes dans la journée la pointe
du matin aux alentours du milieu de la
matinée et la pointe de 19 heures du
soir la pointe de 19 heures du soir a
lieu à 19 heures du soir elle a pas lieu
à 15 heures parce qu'il ya du vent à 15
heures
donc comme vous avez besoin de moyens
pilotable pour assurer la pointe au
moment où elle a lieu pour le moment en
tout cas
eh bien on considère que les moyens
intermittents s'impute sur la balle
je reviendrai après alors quand vous
demande avec un peu ça oblige pas à
changer la façon dont vous envisagez la
base quand vous en avez beaucoup
évidemment ça devient un peu plus un
problème dans les quelques donc ça
l'éolien une fois que vous ai dit ça je
vous ai à peu près tout dit sur la façon
dont ça marche
après quelques éléments complémentaires
pour savoir si on peut en faire beaucoup
ou pas un des premiers éléments sur
l'éolien est de savoir si si on couvre
une superficie suffisamment importante
on est assurés qui est toujours du vent
quelque part de telle sorte qu'on puisse
compter sur une puissance garantie alors
ici vous avez un nuage de points que
j'ai fait il ya pas longtemps où vous
avez pour deux pays adjacent qui sont la
france et l'allemagne
heure par heure quand vous avez 8560
points sur 7 sur ce graphique heure par
heure l'abscisse du point
c'est la fraction du parc allemand qui
est utilisé dit autrement c'est la
fraction de la puissance installée qui
est effectivement produite donc si vous
avez un 20% sur cette valeur et que le
parc installé et de 50 gigawatts
ça veut dire que à ce moment là vous
avez 20 de 50 c'est à dire 10 gigawatts
de produits vous alors j'ai mis en
pourcentage du parc installé ou de la
valeur maximale plus exactement et donc
pas en puissance fournie pour éviter
d'étaler le nuage parce que les
puissances installées dans les deux pays
sont pas du tout les mêmes
là j'ai 100 d'un côté et sanglots de
manière absolument certaine puisque
c'est à chaque fois la fraction de la
puissance installée qui produit
effectivement
alors si vous aviez un foisonnement
parfait c'est à dire si quand y'a pas
devant chez l'un il y en a chez l'autre
et réciproquement les tous les points
devrait se trouver dans une zone qui
ressemble à ça dit autrement quand ça
tourne à plein d'un côté ça tourne pas
du tout de l'autre comme ça je n'ai pas
trop d'électricité
quand ça tourne à plein de l'autre côté
jean n'est pas du tout dans le premier
pays parce que comme ça j'ai pas trop
d'électricité et - journée dans un pays
donné et plus j'en ai dans le pays
adjacent de telle sorte que la somme des
deux est constante
d'accord ça c'est une situation dans
laquelle ça correspond effectivement à
il ya toujours du vent quelque part et
non seulement ignorée par mais il y en a
assez
ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique c'est
que c'est pas ça qu'on observe ce qu'on
observe c'est que la probabilité
maximale de ne pas avoir de vent en
allemagne c'est quand vous avez pas
devant en france donc une autre manière
de dire ça c'est que le fait de regarder
deux pays ensemble plutôt qu'un seul
pays ne vous augmente pas de manière
significative la puissance garantie sur
laquelle vous pouvez compter c'est ça la
conclusion de ce nuage de points c'est
quelque chose que vous pouvez retrouver
sous une autre forme avec ici la
puissance qui est injectée sur une année
alors là vous voyez même pas les minimes
aux minimes annuel parce que ça peut
descendre quasiment là mais la puissance
injectée sur le réseau européen avec
tous les pays qui sont là est ce que
vous voyez c'est que d'aller d'un bout à
l'autre de l'europe va vous voyez ça
vous évite pas quand même de très très
grandes variations de puissance en ce
qui concerne la puissance éolienne
injecté par ailleurs vous voyez ici que
la puissance installée en europe
actuellement ses 170 gigawatts et vous
voyez que ça de montre quasiment jamais
au dessus de 90 donc ça veut dire qu'à
un instant donné
vous ne pouvez jamais avoir la totalité
du ray de la puissance installée qui
produit si je regarde toutes les
éoliennes européenne est par contre à
tout instant la puissance minimale qui
est garantie par ses 170 gigawatts
elle est pas plus élevé que 10 giga
watts ou el-assad et ça descend jusqu'à
10 est en fait si on avait une
résolution plus fine vous verrez que
temps en temps ça descend même un peu en
dessous alors saas apporte une
conséquence importante à avoir en tête
sur la manière de comparer les modes
fatale pv éolien avec les modes
pilotable
ici vous avez la puissance installée en
allemagne depuis 2002 donc voyez en 2002
l'allemagne avait 10 gigawatts de
d'éolien aujourd'hui à l'as en giga
watts solaire éolien offshore éoliens
onshore à terre d'accord 100 gigawatts
qui soit dit en passant mon ordre de
grandeur c'est que ça lui a coûté à peu
près de 150 milliards d'euros installée
voilà maintenant à quoi ressemble la
production électrique renouvelable
alors j'ai un peu triché là dedans parce
que j'ai rajouté le biogaz mais qui est
pilotable et j'ai rajouté
l'hydroélectricité qui est pilotable
mais peu importe
même si vous regardez que la partie
éolienne et solaire vous constatez que
c'est en forte augmentation
ce que vous constatez également si on
regarde la consommation allemande sur
les dix dernières années c'est qu'elle
est à peu près flat
oui là vous avez la colle au maximum de
la consommation allemande les jours à
peu près le même
ce que vous constatez par contre c'est
que les exportations augmentent
viendrait juste après donc ça veut dire
que l'augmentation de la production
électrique allemande en fait c'est
essentiellement à augmenter ses
exportations mais ça nielsen ne baissent
nissan augmente sa consommation
domestique soit dit en passant ce qu'on
voit aussi implicitement sur ce
graphique c'est que l'idée parfois
avancé que si vous avez un panneau dans
le fond de votre jardin ou éolienne dans
le fond de votre jardin ça rend
l'énergie citoyenne c'est à dire que
vous voyez ce qui produit et du coup
vous faites attention à votre facture
ben vous voyez c'est pas totalement
probant quand vous voyez que ça ne bouge
absolument pas au niveau de la
consommation allemands alors avec ce que
je viens de vous montrer donc de plus en
plus de puissance installée de plus en
plus de productions une conservation qui
bouge pas maintenant je vous pose la
question
la puissance installée dans les autres
moyens comment est-ce qu'elle a évolué
il y en a deux qui trichent parce qu'il
connaissait déjà la réponse je pense ça
n'a pas bougé
ici vous avez la puissance installée en
moyens pilotable dans lequel vous avez
remis l'hydroélectricité qui est
pilotable biogaz ici vous avez le
nucléaire dont vous voyez la forte chute
quand ils ont baissé les réacteurs après
vous avez le charbon et vous avez le gaz
alors ligny de charbon gaz ce que vous
voyez c'est qu'eux on avez 100 gigawatts
de puissance pilotable en 2002 savons un
peu ça descend après ça monte un peu ça
descend un peu on a 100 gigawatts
aujourd'hui donc l'augmentation pourtant
pas négligeable puisque izon il avait
100 gigawatts de moyens pilotable ils
ont rajouté 100 autres gigawatts de
moyens intermittents éolien et solaire
et bien ce que vous ne voyez c'est que
l'augmentation de ses moyens
intermittents ne permet pas n'a pas
conduit à baisser la quantité de moyens
pilotable qu'avait l'allemagne du coup
qu'est ce qui s'est passé si la
puissance installée n'a pas varié ils
l'utilisent moins en 2002 ses moyens
pilotable fournissait pas loin de 500
térawattheures d'électricité
aujourd'hui il en fournit un peu moins
de 400 donc en fait ils ont toujours la
même puissance installée
ils ont baissé son facteur de charge
conséquence logique
qu'est ce qui se passe pour les comptes
d'exploitation de ces électriciens il se
casse la gueule et en fait c'est un
processus que vous observez partout en
europe
c'est à dire que les électriciens qui
possédaient des moyens dits
conventionnels avant l'émergence des
nerfs sont tous en train de faire grise
mine
alors dis pas que c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise chose je dis que c'est quelque
chose qu'on doit absolument partout en
europe c'est pas propre à edf qui a
aussi ses comptes ils font un peu grise
mine oui pardon il y avait chez plus une
question devant avant oui là
c'est ce qu'ils font ils l'exportent un
peu là parce que il ya le surplus
d'électricité ici conduit à la fois
abaissé le facteur de charge et à
augmenter les exportations
s'il n'avait pas augmenter les
exportations il baisserait encore plus
le facteur de charge
c'est un arbitrage entre les deux les
exportations soit dit en passant
conduisent aussi à baisser le facteur de
charge des voisins pour exactement les
mêmes raisons oui
attendez je comprends pas là pour le
moment on peut pas marcher on parle
d'électrons et physique 1 ah oui ah non
ils peuvent pas j'ai malheureusement pas
le temps pendant ce court de vous
expliquer longuement en détail pourquoi
mais vous pouvez regarder s'il ya des
conférences de percevoir qui tombe sur
internet ils peuvent pas parce que la
manière dont le marché d'électricité est
organisée c'est qu'à tout instant le
marché s'aligne sur le coût marginal de
production le plus élevé de qui des
moyens disponibles à un instant donné
or le coût marginal de production des
oeillères nuls et donc ça vous tire
globalement le marché vers le bas et
donc ils ne peuvent pas faire monter les
prix voilà c'est dit arrive pas à cause
de ce mécanisme est lent alors on a
inventé une rustine soit dit en passant
qu'on est en train de mettre en place
qu'ils s'appellent les mécanismes de
capacités donc justement comme on sait
qu'on a besoin de garder de la puissance
pilotable l'opérateur dit vous
garantissez que ce truc là est activable
si j'en ai besoin je vous paye pour ça
alors en france du coup si je vous
transpose l'exemple français alors
pardon je vais finir avant voilà le cas
espagnol les espagnols ont installé 25
gigawatts de l'éolienne depuis la fin
des années 90 dans le même temps parce
que il était en train d'équiper leur
part qu'ils ont installé 25 gigawatts de
centrales à gaz
donc en fait ils ont installé très
exactement 1 point entre les modes dont
pilotable et les modes pilotable si les
modes non pilotable était autosuffisant
il aura évidemment pas construit des
centrales à gaz à côté d'accord c'est
une deuxième un deuxième élément qui
montre que ça ne suffit pas d'avoir des
moyens dont pilotable et du coup ce
qu'ils font les espagnols c'est quand il
ya beaucoup de vent et bien ils
utilisent devant puis quand ya pas
beaucoup de vent il utilise le gaz
voilà ça
la conclusion que j'en tire pour la
france c'est que si en france nous
développons fortement les modes non
pilotable donc éolien et solaire
quelles qu'en soient les raisons après
ce que je viens de vous dire et avec
votre propre argent
est-ce que vous avez plutôt envie de
parier qu'on garde autant de réacteurs
nucléaires et combes est facteur de
charge ou plutôt envie de parier qu'on
va supprimer des réacteurs nucléaires
moi avec mon propre argent j'ai envie de
parier qu'on va baisser de facteurs de
charge qu'est ce que ça donne sur la
sûreté du parc cette histoire ça donne
que vous avez un parc vous êtes obligé
de garder pour avoir la puissance
garantie et comme il tourne moins
souvent ou bien ils encaissent moins
d'argent parce que le prix du
mégawattheure n'augmentent pas et donc
vous avez besoin d'entretenir un parc
qui est un système à coûts fixes en
gagnant moins d'argent
est-ce que vous pensez que ça augmente
la sûreté s'est pas complètement sûr ou
bien vous arrivez à faire ce qui a été
suggéré tout à l'heure c'est à dire que
vous vendez votre kilowattheure plus
cher et à ce moment vous avez toujours
le même nombre de réacteurs
vous payez toujours l'électricité
nucléaire le même prix au total pour
moins de kilowattheures et vous avez
rajouté en plus le coût des modes
intermittents ouais d'accord donc mon
pari c'est que si nous allons au bout de
l'expérience du 50% de nucléaire en
france et vous serez encore suffisamment
où seraient vivants au moment où vous
verrez que le pari va au bout ou qu'on
abandonne mon pari c'est que l'essentiel
va être fait non pas en fermant des
réacteurs nucléaires
comment fermera deux ou trois mais ça va
être fait en baissant le facteur de
charge des réacteurs existants et à un
moment ou un autre soit en
recapitalisera soit on ré encadrera les
prix soit il se passera quelque chose de
très bizarre soit et df n'aura plus les
moyens d'assurer la sûreté avec l'argent
qu'elle gagnera en fermera des réacteurs
il y aura des blacks a fallu de toute
façon il va se passer un truc bizarre
la seule chose sur laquelle je ne parie
pas c'est que
va réussir à remplacer des moyens
pilotable par des moyens non pilotable
de façon massive
parce que pour le moment aucun pays
n'arrive à le faire oui non on a enfin
oui en fait oui puisqu'on a décidé en
pratique qu'on allait attendre que
flamanville démarre en ferrain et
fessenheim pour pratiquer oui oui
bien sûr qu'il est pilotable le lady
rapidement la dernière fois mais le
nucléaire vous arriver aujourd'hui à
faire baisser sa puissance de 80% en une
demi heure
il ya la faire remonter dans les mêmes
proportions en une demi-heure aussi vous
avez une marge de 30 mégawatts par
minute sur les réacteurs nucléaires
français
je les ai précisé la dernière fois donc
j'espère que je ne suis pas en train de
préciser un truc que vous étiez en train
de discuter de votre copain à ce moment
là mais je les préciser la dernière fois
et c'est pas le cas de tous les
réacteurs nucléaires dans le monde
mais comme en france on a un gros gros
parc et donc que vous avez besoin
notamment de couvrir une partie de la
variations quotidiennes avec du
nucléaire ce qui était montré sur la
courbe de charge que je peux vous
remonterez s'il est assez comme plus que
vous voyez là que le nucléaire varier un
peu dans la journée et quand la tempête
migaud elle est passée là enfin pas la
tempête me when mais une précédente le
parc nucléaire français a baissé sa
capacité de 10 gigawatts en l'espace
d'une journée
parce qu'il a dû s'effacer justement
devant l'éolien allemand donc
donc oui c'est c'est le nucléaire
français comme comme il est dominant
dans la production
il est capable de faire du suivi de
charge on lui a demandé de faire ça dans
les autres pays quand il fait 20 30 % de
l'approvisionnement alors là c'est clair
qu'il tourne en base à 100% de sa
puissance toute l'année alors l an
dernier point sur l'éolien ce que je
vous montre est aussi partiellement vrai
pour le solaire il ya quelque chose d'un
peu auquel il faut faire attention aussi
c'est que je vous ai montré que les
exportations allemandes avaient augmenté
avec le temps
en fait il ya un pays qui est encore
plus intéressant à regarder de ce point
de vue c'est le danemark ici vous avez
en danemark l'exportation net donc là
ils sont en importation 0 équilibré en
surplus en exportation en fonction de la
puissance éolienne au danemark
vous voyez de manière extrêmement claire
que en gros quand les éoliennes tournent
pas le danemark importe son électricité
de ses voisins notamment du charbon
allemand à queue et parce que quand ya
pas beaucoup de vent
qui n'a pas beaucoup en allemagne non
plus donc c'est justement le moment où
l'allemagne fait tourner ses charbon et
ses centrales à charbon à plein régime
et quand vous avez énormément de vent
est bien le danemark exporte son surplus
et alors ils l'exportent entre autres
vers les pays scandinaves qui ont plein
de barrage dont qu'ils arrêtent leur
barrage qui achète l'électricité là à
zéro voire à moins de zéro et par contre
qu'ils revendent d'électricité des
barrages fort cher au danemark quand on
est là donc les suédois et les
norvégiens adore le programme éolien
danois qu'il ne remercierons jamais
assez
vous avez également le même le même
processus avec l'allemagne où vous avez
alors le nuage de points est un peu
moins resserré mais vous voyez quand
même une tendance très nette au fait que
plus vous avez d'éolien en allemagne et
plus les exportations nettes sont élevés
il ya un autre graphique que je voulais
pas montrer suis désolé mais vous le
pouvez le trouver sur internet sinon je
la joue très ces présentations
vous avez également les prix de marché
qui ont tendance à baisser quand la
puissance éolienne injecté augmente et à
partir du tiers de la puissance
installée
vous commencez à avoir ce qu'on appelle
des prix négatifs c'est à dire que ça
coûte moins cher aux producteurs de
payer le consommateur pour prendre
l'électricité donc on paye le
consommateur pour prendre l'électricité
à ce moment-là pas longtemps et on paye
plutôt que de débrancher l'éolienne
parce que c'est une opération plus
compliqué de la débrancher leurs manches
et voilà quelle est la part de l'éolien
dans la génération électrique d'un
certain nombre de pays alors c'est pas
pour rien que je vous ai montré le
danemark parce que en fait c'est la part
dans la génération électrique ce n'est
pas la part dans la consommation
effective puisqu'une bonne partie de son
électricité exporter son électricité
éolienne est exportée donc la part dans
la consommation effective est beaucoup
plus faible que ça en fait là par
l'union européenne de communicants part
avec ses voisins
au danemark comme ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant c'est de raisonner plutôt
avec ça donc aujourd'hui on est aux
alentours de 10% alors dans l'union
européenne prise globalement le l'éolien
mort quand même sur un peu de fossiles
c'est clair question après si on veut
passer à des modes décentralisée de
manière significative
est-ce qu'on a des limites ailleurs il y
en a une qui est importante
alors qui est peu évoquée mais que vous
voyez ici sur ce graphique que j'ai
tirées d'un document dont vous avez la
référence en battre et qui vous donne
les quantités de matériaux et en
particulier de métaux qui sont utilisés
par tera watt térawattheures du
mégawattheure je sais plus les amateurs
mais en fait c'est le rapport de
proportion qui est qui est important que
vous avez en fonction des modes de
production et ce que vous constatez en
gros c'est que quand vous passez des
modes france on va dire concentré
d'accord dont notamment le nucléaire qui
est décarbonée
mais pas que que vous avez ici à des
modes
[Musique]
diffus on va dire le vent et le solaire
photovoltaïque
vous avez une multiplication par
quelques dizaines à quelques centaines
par exemple cuivre vous voyez la valeur
ici et regarder les valeurs qui sont là
c'est pareil pour le vert regardez les
valeurs c'est pareil pour le ciment
c'est pareil pour l'acier voyez en
bresse donc vous avez un facteur
multiplicateur très important en ce qui
concerne les matériaux qui sont utilisés
par mégawattheure produits or ces
matériaux sont aujourd'hui produits avec
des énergies fossiles
d'accord la mine elle fonctionne
aujourd'hui avec des engins de mines la
métallurgie fonctionne avec du charbon
et d'électricité fossiles les transports
intermédiaire fonctionne avec du pétrole
donc tout ça fonctionne avec des moyens
qui sont des moyens fossiles
l'importance des matériaux que vous avez
là fait que si on devait produire tous
ces matériaux avec juste des panneaux
solaires et des éoliennes serre si on
devait boucler le système il est évident
que le prix de production du solaire et
de l'éolien serait considérablement
supérieur à ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
dit autrement le solaire et l'éolien
aujourd'hui ça coûte pas cher parce que
le dispositif de capture non
renouvelables effet à bas prix parce
qu'on utilise des énergies non
renouvelables pour faire ce dispositif
de capture c'est clair où je le répète
et du coup avec ce que je viens de vous
dire quand on compare le coût d'un
système pilotable avec un système non
pilotable il faut faire très attention
au fait que l'on compare des choux et
des carottes
je le redis vous pouvez pas considérer
qu'un kilowattheure qui fait que votre
cuisinière fonctionne quand vous avez
faim vaut la même chose qu'un
kilowattheure qui fonctionne quand il ya
du vent qui arrive quand ya du vent
parce que si vous n'avez fait un que
quand il ya du vent c'est parfait mais
si vous avez faim à d'autres moments que
quand il ya du vent ça marche moins bien
de même que 1 kilowatt heure qui permet
au train de partir à huit heures quoi
qu'il arrive n'a pas la même valeur
un train un kilowattheure qui permet au
train de partir quand il ya du vent et
donc quand on compare les coûts de
production des votes pilotable et dès
maintenant pilotable j'insiste on
compare des choux et des carottes
il ya que deux manières de comparer les
choses ou bien vous considérez que le
mot tenons pilotable n'évite pas le mode
pilotable ce que je vous ai montré tout
à l'heure quand vous avez des modes
pilotable installez vous rajoutez du nom
pilotable ça vous on salue permet pas
d'enlever du pilotable par contre ça
vous permet de vous en servir - quand
vous ne vous en servez pas ce que vous
économisez c'est le coût du combustible
au moment où vous en servez pas d'accord
le coût du combustible quand vous vous
en servez pas dans une centrale à ligny
tellement c'est 20 euros c'est 10 euros
du mégawattheures dans une centrale à
charbon dans le monde ces quelques
dizaines d'euros du 20 euros allez on va
dire du mégawattheure et dans une
centrale à gaz c'est 50 euros du
mégawattheures dans une centrale
nucléaire c'est de l'ordre de deux euros
par mégawattheure
donc le coût du combustible et éviter
peut se comparer au coût complet du mode
non pilotable ça c'est une première
comparaison qui est légitime la deuxième
comparaison c'est dire je vais carrément
supprimer le vote pilotable à ce moment
vous devez rajouter le coût du stockage
au mode non pilotable vous devez refaire
un système pilotable et le coût du
stockage
je voulais dit tout à l'heure ça vous
conduit à multiplier par n'importe quoi
entre deux et cinq fois j'ai pas dit
mais je veux pas c'est ça vous convient
à x n'importe quoi entre 2 et 5 le coût
de production du mode non pilotable et
donc quand vous faites réintervenir le
coût du stockage dont 4 intervenir le
coût du stockage
ça va évidemment rendre l'équation
totalement différent donc si je prends
un mégawatt heure éolien en sortie
d'éoliennes niveau 50 euros très bien
mais une fois que je les stocker
restitués ça va plutôt se rapprocher de
100 à 150 et ça encore une fois c'est
dans un monde dans lequel j'ai des
énergies fossiles pour me faire
l'éolienne et dispositifs de stockage
oui
c'est très difficile de calculer un coût
de changements d'habitudes l'ademe quand
elle a sorti son rapport 100% vénère là
à supposer qu'ils avaient les deux tiers
de la puissance appelée dans le pays qui
était déplaçables sans investissements
nécessaires sans investissements
nécessaires c'est un postulat arni pour
ne pas dire plus parce que les habitudes
sauf à ce que vous arrivez chez tout le
monde avec le fusil c'est pas si simple
que ça a changé parce que y'en a plein
qui correspondent à des contraintes que
vous changez pas si facilement je vais
vous donner un exemple si vous invitez
tous seuls et que vous faites ce qui est
une très bonne chose que vous l'avez aux
chemises vous même et bien ou bien vous
lavez vos chemises quand vous êtes chez
vous et pas en cours ou bien vous lavez
vos chemises quand il ya du vent pour ça
faut vous ayez une machine programmables
il faut soit dit en passant que vous
rentriez chez vous pas longtemps après
la fin de la lessive parce que si vous
rentrez chez vous 2 jours après la fin
de l'année si vous pouvez recommencer
parce que tout a moisi
donc vous avez besoin d'investir dans
quelque chose qui est soit une machine
programme alors que vous l'avez pas soit
une machine programmables plus le voisin
qui passe chercher votre linge ou une
femme de ménage que vous payez mais dans
tous les cas de figure c'est pas quelque
chose de totalement anodin donc l'idée
qu'il n'ya pas d'argent à mettre dans
l'est dans l'adaptation à une offre
fluctuante moi c'est une hypothèse qui
me semble parfaitement farfelues
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est coût
implicite d'adaptation à une offre qui
n'est plus garantie ils sont réels donc
soit il ya des coûts d'adaptation soyez
les coûts de stockage et donc vous ne
vous n'avez pas quand on dit
l'éolien c'est moins cher que le
nucléaire parce que l'éolien c'est 60
euros le nucléaire c'est 100 euros on
compare des choux et des carottes
ce qu'il faut comparer c'est soit le
coût du combustible et éviter dans le
nucléaire quand on s'en sert pas ça oui
soit le coût de l'éolien stocker
restituer plus renforcement réseau je
vous faire une petite règle de trois en
trois secondes comparé
au nucléaire ou au charbon ou regardent
soit dit en passant même principe
alors voilà une petite règle de trois
que je peux tenter pour vous donner pour
vous donner un ordre de grandeur à
gauche
j'ai un système 100% nucléaire alors mon
système 100% nucléaire soit dit en
passant il est possible parce que comme
je le disais tout à l'heure avec le
nucléaire je peux faire de suivi de
charge
donc je peux très bien avoir un système
dans lequel je n'ai que du nucléaire si
c'est des réacteurs mode français à
droite
j'ai un système dans lequel je n'ai que
de l'éolien avec évidemment le stockage
alors mon facteur de charge si j'ai que
de nucléaire
il va se balader aux alentours de 70 %
sur l'année parce que je peux pas avoir
100% puisque j'ai des fluctuations 100%
l'éolien continental il est aux
alentours de 20 c'est avec ça que j'ai
fait mes calculs si on met de l'off
shore c'est plutôt 25 ou 30 mai mettons
que ce soit pas ça veut dire que pour
une même quantité d'électricité utilisée
à la fin de l'année j'ai besoin de trois
à quatre fois plus de puissance
installée en éolien qu'en nucléaire
puisque mon facteur de charge et 3,4
fois plus bas après mon éolienne va
durer 20 à 30 ans mon réacteurs il peut
durer 60
donc je dois rejouer une fois mettons
deux quand je suis en éolien versus
quand je suis en nucléaire
après si je suis en nucléaire j'ai pas
besoin de coûts additionnels dans le
réseau il existe déjà
alors que si je me mets des éoliennes
partout j'ai des raccordements à faire
dans tous les sens
et puis si j'ai trois à quatre fois plus
de puissance installée
instantané ça veut dire que va y avoir
des moments où au lieu de cracher 100
gigawatts mon appareil de production
également craché 250 il n'arrivera
jamais au total des 300 à 400 mais il va
quand même entre h et 250 aujourd'hui le
réseau est pas dimensionné pour ça donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut je renforce le
réseau
après il va falloir que je stocke une
partie de l'électricité produite alors
si je suis en pur éolien j'ai plus ni
verger - l'été si je suis en pur solaire
c'est l'exact inverse si j'ai un mélange
des deux je lis un peu sur l'année mais
j'ai quand même besoin de stockage inter
saisonniers et donc ça semble augmenter
mon coup là j'ai fait le calcul j'ai
fait le l'hypothèse que j'allais
construire dès stocks dans les alpes
justement c'était là des stations de
pompage avec l'eau du léman par contre
le nucléaire reste plus cher au kilo
watt installé quand on fait vraiment
n'importe quoi c'est 7000 euros comme à
flamanville si on fait venir les chinois
s'assoient 3000 puisque c'est à peu près
ce qu'ils ont payé à taishan
voilà donc c'est pour ça que j'ai mis 3
à 5 livres en série par contre l'éolien
c'est beaucoup moins cher c'est 1500
voire éventuellement ville donc l'âge
est un facteur 2 3 voire 4 en défaveur
du nucléaire mais si je fais la somme
des fois été divisées ici je me retrouve
à l'arrivée avec au premier ordre un
besoin en capitaux qui est d'un ordre de
grandeur au dessus si j'ai un système
totalement basée sur du nom pilotable
donc voilà une règle de trois c'est un
peu rustique mais ça vous permet de
sentir l'ordre de grandeur et ça vous
permet de constater que contrairement à
une idée couramment répandue en termes
d'investissement qui sont nécessaires
pour que le système fonctionne en mode
pilotable insiste si c'est en mode non
pilotable il faudra rajouter les
investissements vous éviter de stockage
mais vous rajoutez les investissements
chez les particuliers pour qu'ils
s'adaptent au fait que de temps en temps
il y a pas d'électricité
donc vous rajouterez les batteries chez
les particuliers vous rajouterez tous
les appareils programme chez les
particuliers et c'est donc savoure
ajoutera du capex chez les particuliers
du capital voilà donc c'est juste pour
dire en fait contrairement à une idée
couramment répandue ce système là est
beaucoup plus cher que ce système là est
la raison pour laquelle on a fait dans
un premier temps en des mode centralisé
de grosse puissance avec un réseau c'est
juste
parce que c'est moins cher c'est
justement pour ça que tous les pays au
monde ont fait exactement comme ça
les gros mots de centraliser avec un
réseau on peut mettre les éoliennes au
dessus de la surface on peut également
la m sous la surface
alors quand on met l'éolienne sous la
surface de l'océan ça s'appelle une
hydrolienne l'hydrolienne c'est fait
pour capter les courants marins et les
courants de marée pardon qui sont
particulièrement fort en manche et puis
sur le pourtour de la grande bretagne
et puis ils sont particulièrement forts
près de l'agcom vous pouvez le voir
répondre à une question qui m'a été
posée tout à l'heure l'intérêt des
courants de marée par rapport au vent et
au soleil
c'est qu'ils sont totalement prévisible
non seulement calendaire mmm et en
amplitude l'école pour ceux d'entre vous
qui sont aux bretons et des bretons ici
bon donc vous savez puisque vous avez
regardé les l'étape de marée que l'on
connaît les coefficients de marée les
moments où il faut aller chasser les
palourdes 3 32 ans à l'avancé aucun
problème donc on à l'amplitude de la
marée est connue très longtemps à l
avance et le moment dans la journée où
elle arrive aussi ce qui veut dire qu'en
mettant des hydroliennes au bon endroit
c'est-à-dire espacées d'un quart de
longueur d'onde
vous pouvez avoir un approvisionnement
garanti assez significatif c'est ça le
sessad idée alors par contre ça pose un
certain nombre d'inconvénients les
hydroliennes
vous travaillez en milieux salés il ya
un conflit d'usagé avec les pêcheurs
parce que les pêcheurs ont envie d'aller
racler les fonds pile là où vous mettez
des hydroliennes
ça demande beaucoup beaucoup de
matériaux par mégawatt de puissance
installée
beaucoup donc c'est bon c'est
intéressant mais c'est limite bon vous
pouvez utiliser l'énergie des vagues
regardez la puissance de cette affaire
là
750 kg bon 100 gigawatts de puissance
électrique installée en france on peut
en faire quelques uns si on veut faire
si on veut faire des reportages
télévisuels amusant mais bon ça va faire
beaucoup plus que ça on peut utiliser
des machines thermodynamique qui
exploite la différence de température
alors ça c'est une machine de carnot
particulièrement inefficace
oui il faut que j'accélère parce qu'il
reste 10 minutes
donc c'est un truc que vous avez pas
compris ou à la fin du cours alors on
peut faire des machine thermodynamique
des machines de cardio particulièrement
inefficace avec une différence entre la
température de surface qui aux alentours
de 30 degrés enfin 25 30 degrés et
l'autre profonde qui à 4 degrés partout
dans le monde et à ce moment vous
exploitez la différence en faisant avec
une grande circulation d'eau voilà c'est
un truc qui peut s'envisager
si on regarde à l'arrivée et ce que
coûte ces trucs différents
voilà à quoi ressemble les énergies
aujourd'hui que nous avons dans entre
guillemets le concentré et dans le
déconcentrer voilà ce que nous avons en
termes de en termes de prix et j'insiste
encore une fois si on le fait que ça
c'est aujourd'hui produit avec ça on n'a
pas un système autonome
ça j'y insiste quand on aura que des
panneaux solaires et des éoliennes pour
faire de la mine et de la métallurgie et
des transports on reparlera du coût des
éoliennes des panneaux solaires
alors ça veut pas dire qu'on peut pas en
faire plus parce que je suis en train de
dire ça veut juste dire que pour le
moment la baisse de coûts très forte
qu'on a eue est un effet de la
mondialisation c'est un effet de la
mondialisation
enfin on peut finir en disant qu' on
peut également utiliser
l'énergie des marées donc ça c'est le
barrage hydroélectrique de la rance
les bretons connaissent évidemment enfin
sauf ceux qui habitent dans le morbihan
mais qui sont pas des preuves en tant
attendu si vous croisez un bigouden
quand même c'est rien une fois qu'on a
fait le panorama donc vous avez ici la
part des énergies renouvelables dans
l'approvisionnement énergétique d'un
certain nombre de pays alors vous voyez
que c'est pas la norvège qui gagne c'est
l'islande
parce que dans la partie vert clair en
bas en fait j'ai mis nouvelles
renouvelables en fait c'est pas des
nouvelles renouvelables là dedans vous
avez la géothermie qui est une ancienne
renouvelables donc l'islande est aussi
un très très gros consommateurs
d'électricité par personne et les
islandais utilise à la fois beaucoup
d'hydroélectricité mais aussi beaucoup
de géothermie donc là d'un vrai je
n'arrive qu'en deuxième position
alors vous voyez que dans cette
affaire-là si on regarde la france la
france n'est pas extrêmement bien placé
la france est placée
[Musique]
j'y arrive
ou est-ce qu'on a la france on est
encore plus à droite parce qu'on est à
oui effectivement mais là vous voyez on
est on est bas on est à 10% en gros donc
si on dit est en fait la raison et cela
c'est que dans les pays qui sont assez
plat et assez densément peuplées il ya
bien pire que nous en europe
les hollandais et les belges si on est
assez plat et assez densément peuplées
on peut oublier en fait les énergies
renouvelables parce que enfin en
substitution rapide parce que les deux
grandes énergies renouvelables dans le
monde je le répète c'est
l'hydroélectricité la biomasse c'est là
que vous avez du stock
la biomasse à une fonction de stock le
barrage à une fonction de stocks que ni
le vent ni soleil non et vous avez
besoin d'espacé de montagne ainsi vous
voulez avoir beaucoup de forêts et
beaucoup de barrages
donc si vous êtes dans un pays qui est
richement doté en forêt et richement
doté en barrages ce qui en europe est le
cas par exemple de la scandinavie ski en
amérique du sud est par exemple le cas
du brésil où par exemple cas de la
colombie etc ou par exemple le cas du
canada amérique du nord est bien à ce
moment et vous avez une population pas
trop importants dans le pays
vous pouvez rêver dans
l'approvisionnement qui serait 100%
renouvelable si vous êtes dans un pays
plat et densément peuplées typiquement
la belgique
ça devient très compliqué et en fait
l'équation commence à être un peu plus
jouable à partir du moment où vous fait
rentrer la totalité du décarbonés et
notamment le nucléaire pour autant pour
finir avec est ce qu'on va devenir un
jour 100% renouvelable 100% renouvelable
dans un contexte de pib croissant car je
vous signale que même le scénario
négawatt considère que le pib va croître
un économiste qui a fait un scénario
enfin qu'il ya qui a proposé le volet
économique du scénario négawatt en
disant que le pib allait croître
exactement comme dans les stratégies
nationales bas carbone
à ce moment ça veut dire que vous devez
satisfaire une équation de ce type
vous devez avoir de plus en plus
d'énergie parce que le pib répond
essentiellement la quantité de machines
en fonctionnement dans quelle énergie et
vous devez avoir de moins en moins de
fossiles et donc le rythme de croissance
qu'on doit avoir pour le décarbonés 6 7%
par an si on veut tenir les accords de
paris il a danger inclut le nucléaire si
on met pas le nucléaire le rythme de
croissance sur les autres zehner c'est
plutôt 10 % par an alors voilà on va
jouer comme le banquier avec les
intérêts composés
si je fais 7% par an sur 30 ans a fait
foi cette est simple 7,7 alors question
est-ce que je peux plus je peux
multiplier par sept
l'approvisionnement en biomasse bas si
on est toujours aussi nombreux qu'on
cultive toujours autant même si on mange
moins de viande mais que l'agriculture
devient moins productif parce qu'on met
moins d'engrais et moins de
phytosanitaires
enfin voilà il ya retombe sur ce qui
s'est passé à l'origine quand on était
100% le nerfs avec un problème de
concurrence d'usagé des sols qui qu'on
peut pas utiliser les sols pour faire
tout à la fois donc utiliser les sols
pour faire à la fois de l'agriculture
très extensive et plein de forêt et tout
ça avec une planète à 8 milliards
d'individus
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué pareil
pour l'hydroélectricité est ce que je
peux multiplier les lacs de barrage par
set alors c'est tout ça en même temps
j'insiste puisque c'est 7% pour
l'ensemble de l'approvisionnement
renouvelables on est d'accord c'est tout
ça en même temps ça peut paraître la
biomasse ou les barrages c'est tout un
an
donc est-ce que je peux dans le même
temps et en 30 ans multiplié par sept
les lacs de barrage bon voilà je vous
parlais des agrocarburants donc dans un
monde dans lequel on doublerait la
mobilité et où ça serait fait avec des
agrocarburants vous voyez aujourd'hui on
consomme 4 milliards de tonnes de
pétrole par an un peu plus 4,2 il
faudrait donc passé à 8000
peut-être 8 milliards de tonnes de
carburant sachant que aujourd'hui les
agrocarburants dont 170 millions est-ce
qu'on va y arriver
c'est pas complètement sûr et c'est donc
là la réponse c'est que il n'est pas
complètement certain quand on joue avec
les règles de trois qu'on retombe sur
les résultats des modèles sophistiqués
qui disent que 100% aux nerfs on va y
arriver
alors là je vous rappelle une règle
essentielle que je vous invite à garder
en tête toute votre vie professionnelle
durant quand une règle de trois qui vous
semblent pas complètement déconnante
invalide les résultats d'un modèle très
sophistiqué auquel vous ne comprenez
rien c'est que le modèle à tort et donc
la seule bonne question c'est de savoir
où mais j'insiste c'est pas parce que le
modèle et sophistiquée et que vous y
comprenez rien que le modèle est plus
intelligent goût s'il n'est pas capable
de vous retrouver les ordres de
grandeurs auquel vous parvenez avec une
règle de trois bien poser c'est que le
modèle il faut il ya plein de modèles
justin en rien le modèle qui fait voler
l'avion est juste l'avion s'écrase pas
jacques atterrissage donc il ya plein de
modèles juste mais si encore une fois ce
à quoi vous arriver qu'une règle de
trois ne recoupe pas un modèle
sophistiqué ces clubs de la torre alors
est ce qu'on peut faire
7 % 10% 15% 20% parce qu'il est évident
que si on est limité sur ces trucs là ça
veut dire que là je dois faire et en
particulier sur le solaire et l'éolien
je dois faire des pourcentages de
croissance de 20 30 40 % par an on est
d'accord
question est ce que dans le passé on a
su faire quelques dizaines 2% de
croissance par an longtemps et bien je
vous remontre un ensemble de courts
parce que je vous avais montré ça juste
pour le pétrole rappelez vous je vous
avais montré le rythme de croissance de
la production de pétrole dans le monde
sur le dernier siècle et demi et je vous
avais montré que partant de 15% par hans
étaient descendus maintenant quasiment à
zéro
vous pouvez faire ça avec toutes les
énergies sur lesquels vous avez des
séries longues
est ce que vous voyez c'est que des
énergies qui reste en taux de croissance
au-dessus de 10% pendant très longtemps
ça n'arrive jamais et même le nucléaire
qui étaient partis de très très long
parce que quand vous partez de l'epsilon
c'est facile
des très forts taux de croissance tous
les ans est bien très très vite vous
retomber à des taux de croissance qui
sont inférieures à 5 ou 10%
donc l'idée que c'est donc si je prend
le problème à l'envers si j'applique 8%
de taux de croissance à ça et ça pendant
roskill aimons ce que je voulais vous
dire c'était sans doute en 10 % de
croissance en 30 ans vous tombez
absolument pas sur ce qui permet
d'éviter les deux tiers ou les trois
quarts des combustibles fossiles en 30
ans voilà donc la conclusion de secours
sur les énergies renouvelables
c'est par là que j'ai commencé c'est à
dire ça recoupe des réalités très
diverses
c'est très dépendant de la géographie
d'un pays donc tous les pays partent pas
à armes égales dans la course
si vous avez beaucoup de soleil pour
exploiter le soleil vous êtes quand même
mieux partis que la suède ou
l'antarctique
si vous avez beaucoup de forêts c'est
quand même beaucoup plus facile de
chauffer tout le monde au bois ou de
chauffer et quasiment tout le monde au
bois comme en suède que si vous êtes en
belgique
si vous avez beaucoup de montagne c'est
beaucoup plus facile comme les
norvégiens d'avoir plein de barrage et
en plus beaucoup de montagne par
habitant est de consommer trois fois
l'électricité qu'on a en france que si
vous êtes à nouveau en belgique etc
les énergies renouvelables c'est très
très dépendant des conditions
géographiques locales et considérer que
partout dans le monde
ces énergies vont permettre de nous
débarrasser des énergies fossiles alors
même que historiquement celle inverse
qui s'est passé et tout ça pour pas cher
est un résultat sur lequel à titre
personnel je ne parierais pas mes
propres deniers
donc il est vraisemblable que l'avenir
qui va s'écrire et dont on parlera la
prochaine fois de la méthode de gestion
qui va avec de la comptabilité carbone
l'avenir qui va s'écrire sera dans tous
les cas de figure fait d'un mélange
d'économie d'énergie et donc pour partie
de contraction économique de nucléaire
et des énergies renouvelables dans des
proportions qui dépendront pour le coup
des contextes géographiques politiques
et sociaux et culturels locaux voilà et
bien à la prochaine fois